And we're live.
Are you going to update the people out
there?
No.
Oh,
you shut your phone off while you're a
professional drone racer.
Good.
Going.
Well,
it's going on.
Um,
everything.
It's all pretty weird out there.
It is very weird out there.
We were just talking about how weird it
is out there,
um,
before the podcast about how it just
seems like it's very difficult to keep
it together during these times and to
keep a reasonable position and to handle
all of the pressure of all the people
that get upset at anything you do left
or right in the middle.
Centrist your two centers due to left
you to write your unreasonable.
You're to reasonable.
You're too nice.
You're not nice enough.
Well,
suddenly I feel like I'm in a marriage
doesn't seem like it does.
I think that this is why this is the era
for disagree ability.
If you're not easily swayed because
you're somehow a insensitive enough that
you just want to keep to first
principles wherever it is that you
believe.
That seems to be the best hedge against
getting swept up in the madness of
others.
How so?
Well,
um,
I guess when I go metacognitive I look
at my yearning for group belonging and
then I also watch my inability to belong
to groups that say crazy things.
And so those are,
those are two conflicting feelings.
I think sometimes when people look at me
they say,
wow,
you're really contrarian and you have an
easy time standing up to the
conventional wisdom.
And I don't think it's,
it's,
it's that true.
I just think when those two things fight
inside me,
a dialectically the disagree ability is
so strong because it's protecting a
comprehensive view of the world.
And so since everything already kind of
fits together fairly well,
I would say I'm much,
it's much harder to sway me because the
number of things I would have to move
cognitively to accommodate a wrong idea.
This is quite large.
It seems unnecessary,
but it also seems like we should be able
to disagree on things and you should be
able to point out with reasonable
courtesy that there's something wrong
with someone's idea and it not become a
big personal thing.
But oftentimes that's not the case.
Well.
So a lot of the things I think that
we're,
we're exploring or what I would think of
as Heuristics,
they're sort of rules of thumb that
worked fairly well within some domain of
definition and we've gotten so many of
these conflicting rules.
I mean the rules of thumb themselves,
conflict.
So for example,
he who has the,
his last,
uh,
conflicts with,
um,
nothing ventured,
nothing gained or something like that.
Uh,
sorry.
Um,
it's a,
I forget know there's the cautionary.
I'm aphorism and then there's the be
bold,
the aphorism.
And so we don't have a good way of
sorting out conflicts that occurred.
The heuristic level.
Then you also have heuristics
meant for social cohesion,
conflicting with ground truth.
So this is why biology is always
controversial because biology is a
science that tells us many of the things
that we wish were true or just not true.
You know,
I always think about Ben Shapiro's
facts.
Don't care about your feelings.
Well,
biology cares about your feelings.
Just laughs at them and stomps on them
and makes them feel very sad.
Well,
it also tries to explain your feelings,
right?
Exactly.
But you know,
if you really understand biology,
the world is so dark and so interesting
and beautiful and crazy that it's very
hard to recover simple ideas about how
people should be once you really
realized that are being apes has deep
consequences.
Yeah.
I have a very minimal understanding of
biology.
But in that understanding,
I've come to accept some things just
about being a person that I never
considered before such as all the
different things that are running your
decision making,
like just what we're talking about.
Like the,
the need to be in a group and all of
these are probably evolutionary
advantages to fostering tribal behavior.
So you could all work together and feed
each other.
You know,
this,
this is always pulling at you and you
know,
when,
when people give people hard time about
virtue signaling,
it is kind of gross.
When someone virtue signals,
you know,
but we understand what it is.
It's gross because we've all done it.
Right?
That's one of the gross things about it.
When someone is just like really trying
hard to act like,
you know,
they're disgusted by the way people
behave because they would never behave
like that and they just want to let you
know,
I'm,
I'm above this type of behavior.
What's most likely because they weren't
above that kind of behavior at some
point in their life or they're not
currently really above that type of
behavior,
but they wish they were or the part of
them that speaking is the part that's
above that behavior.
But that's not the part that's going to
be operative after 11 on a weekend at a
bar.
Yeah.
Three shots in all bets are off.
The wheels are off the wagon.
So I think we don't,
we don't see ourselves.
We are permanently in our own blind spot
because the part of us that is just and
righteous and good,
um,
seems to know very little about the
other part.
What's also this thing,
this need to belong and need to be
accepted.
Like we work to be accepted instead of
work to be someone that you would want
to be a part of the group instead of
being like really honest about who you
are and how you think and how you behave
and how you operate in the world.
Instead of doing that and trying to
improve upon that.
You try to project an image of this.
Well then here's a question for us.
Why is vice signaling so much more
powerful than virtue signaling?
Vice signaling.
Like a person who admits their problems,
like an alcoholic who steps up and says,
I've got a real issue.
Could be that way.
Or it could be sort of Dan Bilzerian
type vibe.
Like you want to know what I'm into.
I'm into hot chicks weed and guns and
I'm making tons of money and showing it
off.
Well,
he's super honest right now.
That's one of the reasons.
And you he's bulletproof in that regard.
Like you can't fuck with him.
Like you can't say,
hey,
look at you.
You're just a playboy.
He'd be like,
yeah,
yeah.
Like girls.
Yeah,
it works.
Yeah.
Um,
what else?
Right now I'm nice,
like he's a nice guy.
Talked to Dan Bilzerian.
He's friendly,
he's not bad guy.
No,
I mean he,
he,
you know,
he had a,
he had this post which was a,
he was I think offering a hand to a
woman up the stair and said,
come with me.
I'll ruin your life,
but it'll be fun.
No,
it was just like,
it's so disarming and I think that this
is also partially,
you know,
a secret to your success,
which is that you're a nice guy.
You're really into fighting,
you know,
you,
you hunt elk,
you're clear about which ones you're
going to kill,
which ones you want based on the
reproductive cycle.
You're,
you're promoting all sorts of things
that people don't want to talk about to
a fairly conscious level.
And it's produced an incredible level of
trust in an era where all of the virtue
signaling gives way.
I mean,
I mean if you scratch any person a
enough below the surface,
you're going to see that they're really
warning you about themselves.
And so the people who are the most sort
of self critical,
and this is like,
you know,
I think I brought this up recently a on
twitter about Metta honesty,
where there was a in the Castro in San
Francisco,
there was a bar and restaurant that was
advertising a free food naked servers
plus false advertising.
You know,
it was just fun and playful.
And as a result,
uh,
you know,
you had an instant desire to,
to eat there and to trust them.
And so I think that in this world of
virtue signaling,
vice signaling is really the growth
industry and that's what's working for
good people because they are more in
touch and you know,
they are going to lie to you and they're
going to do all the self interested
things,
but they're not going to
surprise you quite as much.
Well,
in the case of Dan Bilzerian,
I really don't think he's going to lie
to you.
I don't think that's what he's doing.
I think what he's doing is living like a
guy who's got $100,
million dollars and happens to be 35
years old and likes to bang hot chicks
and fly around in private jets and live
in some fucking house that he's got.
He just bought some crazy house and like
Bel Air,
I guess with that weed money Jesus,
he's got.
It looks like you'd probably cost
$100,000,000
or something ridiculous like that.
It's a fucking insane house,
but that's what he likes.
The guy drives,
likes to drive around Ferrari's and d,
but he's a nice guy,
so it's like,
well,
what,
where?
What's what's wrong with this picture?
What's wrong with this picture is he's
doing things that I look at this.
This is this house.
What in the holy fuck is that?
Does he have a golf course on his roof?
What is that?
This is a fucking ridiculous house.
Look at this fucking place.
He gives his address out,
so that is address.
It's pretty hard to hide that thing.
Why the fuck would he give his address?
Alex?
I don't think you can get there.
It's in Bel Air.
Whoa.
Look at this house.
It's preposterous.
Anyway,
this is what he likes,
but why is that bad?
I mean,
look,
we only have
100 years.
If everything goes perfect.
I know.
What do you give a shit?
Like why does everybody get a ship?
But they do give a shit.
They give a shit a lot because for a lot
of folks that are working,
you know,
making a good living,
making 50 grand a year,
whatever.
That's it
completely out of the realm of
possibility and his lifestyle wouldn't
be sustainable for them.
I mean because he's taking real risks.
There's no question about it.
When you get everybody stoned and then
you take them to fire automatic weapons
out in the desert.
Oh yeah.
That's real risk.
And also the gambling,
he does a lot of like crazy gambling.
Well,
but this is the thing about the
relationship with the unforgiving.
This is partially why I think your UFC
and Jujitsu life is that when you have a
relationship with the unforgiving,
you can say,
you know that guy,
that guy doesn't really know what he's
doing,
but then you're,
you're in the ring,
you know,
you're the man in the arena and you find
out very quickly whether or not the
trash talking,
you know,
paid off or it didn't.
And I think that many people have no
relationship with the unforgiving.
Like they'll take them out on a hike
into the,
let's say the Trinity Wilderness,
and then two hours.
Then they'll just sit down and say,
I want to go home.
Right?
You're thinking like,
okay,
you're signaling something,
but there's,
there's no car service and there's,
we're not calling a helicopter.
You know,
it just that there's this.
If you live in the social layer,
you're surprised by the existence of the
unforgiving.
But oh well,
one on one hand,
I want to support people's ability to do
whatever the fuck they want.
On one hand,
I want to support someone's ability to
sit in front of a computer and whether
you're working or you're writing code or
you're writing a script or you're just a
fucking playing video games,
I want to support your ability to do
whatever you want to do.
If you.
If you have the means,
if you're not,
you know,
if your family is starving,
this is what you enjoy doing.
Why do I care?
But as a person who's experienced a fair
amount of adversity,
especially selfimposed adversity,
I would,
I would tell you that you would benefit
from it.
I've benefited from it and I think you'd
benefit from it too.
You don't want to be that guy.
The two hours into the hike says,
I want to go home.
You don't want to be that guy.
You want to be.
That person just says,
well,
this is what we're doing and I'm going
to figure out how to do this and I'm
going to show character and I'm gonna.
I'm going to be proud of myself at the
end of this.
I mean not might have to walk for six
hours and when it's all over,
my legs might be shaky and I might have
to sit down,
but that gatorade is going to taste so
good.
It's going to be like the greatest
gatorade of all time because he's going
to drink and you'd be like,
oh,
or are in the shit out of this.
You're going to feel it.
And I think we learned about ourselves
through especially self.
Well,
any kind of adversity,
you know,
look,
I'm coming off of being evacuated from
the fires,
which was for me not that difficult.
You know,
I'm not poor.
I got a hotel,
I brought my family to the hotel.
We got safe,
got my dog to the,
to the podcast studio.
And everybody's all right,
you know.
But for those firefighters,
I mean 12 hour shifts.
The blaze
for people who lost their homes,
some of them tried to save it.
There was a story about a guy in Malibu,
the climbed on top of his roof with a
hose and tried to fight off the fire and
he got severe burns and he's in the
hospital.
And I mean,
it's raining ash and these chunks of
fucking fire on people,
these embers,
they're falling from the sky and this
guy's trying to save his house.
I mean,
that guy literally went through the
fires.
He'll be a different person after this
and no question.
We've been in something of a reality
drought.
The number of people who have very
little relationship to reality.
I mean,
you know,
I used to live in Cambridge,
Massachusetts and you'd,
you'd come in from Boston and there
would be the science at fresh killed
chicken bones about it,
man.
Fresh killed chicken.
But like chicken mcnuggets,
nobody quite knows what,
what part of the chicken isn't mcnugget
right?
It's just some abstraction that comes to
you.
And so I think we've gotten very
divorced.
There'll all of these layers of
indirection between us and the world.
And when a fire happens,
it's so overwhelming.
We were just choking on the SF smoke,
uh,
in the bay area.
There's,
it,
it just,
it gets real after having been unreal
for a very long time.
Yeah,
it's unavoidable.
It makes you,
it makes you buck up like you gotta get
Outta there.
Like we got evacuated Thursday at 2:30
in the morning.
We were looking up.
We were like,
we gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
I don't give a shit what you leave
behind.
Just go keep your body and go everything
else.
It's either replaceable or you don't
really need it that much.
Anyway.
Just fucking get out of there.
And when you see that fire raging over
those hills and helicopters dropping
water on it and then another house
explodes because the gas line gets hit.
It's just you,
you saw that,
you see that you go,
oh,
there's not enough people in the world
to save you.
There's not enough fucking firefighters
or cops.
There's too many houses as too many
people and a bunch of these houses are
going to go.
You've got to get the fuck out of there.
And um,
but there's a certain.
I was with a bunch of my friends from my
neighborhood and my friend Tom Segura
and his wife,
we all stayed at the same hotel and we
felt we.
There was like a tangible sense of
community with this.
I love this point.
Let's imagine you go for a wedding and
they house you with your third cousins.
People you barely know.
If you're lucky enough that the sewage
system breaks and like stuff is leaking
out of the ceiling and you guys all have
to do heroic,
crazy stuff to save the house.
You're going to be closer to your third
cousin than you are to your uncle.
Right?
And this is this very strange feature of
the world that is kind of a random
arrival of diversity is very often what
bonds you to some particular human
being.
And if you avoid adversity in groups
your whole life,
you probably don't realize that a,
you're never fully activated as a human
being or particularly,
you know,
if,
if men I think don't form groups that in
some sense fight or battle or contest
together.
So there's this very weird fact that
apparently humans are the only species
that organize a contests in teams.
Um,
you know,
this is an intrinsic feature of being
human contests.
Do other animals have any contests?
Well,
just so they spiked chimps,
you know,
we'll,
we'll have these incredible raiding
parties were very methodical and
they'll,
they'll attack somebody else,
but I don't think that they practice it.
It's like,
okay,
your red team,
chimp,
what were the only ones that do stuff
like that that can communicate,
right?
Like dolphins can communicate,
but they don't do stuff like that.
Right?
Or you have individual sparring,
like you'll have two bears learning to
play with each other,
um,
because it's safer to play with your
brother and childhood than it is to just
suddenly show up against some big ass
bear and have to compete for females.
I had William von Hippel on a couple of
days ago and he's the author of the
social leap and uh,
we were actually talking about this,
about one of the things that made human
being successful as we came down from
the trees and started walking around the
grasslands is our ability to organize
and to work and coordinate together.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
like African wild dogs are fairly good
at this and you watch what they do in
their spare time very often.
They just take the piss out of each
other so that they actually come to each
other's age eight at a very high level,
uh,
in times of need.
But like,
you know,
when you're just hanging out around the
fire hose firehouse,
you're,
you're really just giving each other
shit all the time.
And so there's something about the way
in which we play.
I'm being kind of divergent from the way
in which we behave when we actually just
need each other and like,
you,
you need to be on that line,
you know,
let's say,
uh,
you know,
throwing burlap bags and I just need you
to do that thing.
And we were both facing something
together.
Uh,
it does not.
It doesn't have to be fighting in a
militaristic situation.
But I do think that,
um,
this is one of the weird things that's
going on with all of this emphasis on
care and feelings,
is that often men need to give each
other shit in order to form very deep
bonds.
If I can't tease you and if I don't know
where the line is like there is this
line which is like,
dude,
that was way too far.
We all know that those lines exist and
we sometimes have to go up to them and
sometimes we have to experiment by going
over them,
but if somebody says,
I don't like the way you're talking,
it seems very insensitive and my
response is,
well,
you're going to keep me from forming a
deep bond with that person.
You just don't know that that's how we
do it.
Yeah.
They're shielding their.
They're putting up their shield and
often is to project a certain image to
you.
They,
they,
they want to be taken seriously.
They want some respect.
They
can't deal with you goofing on them.
That's true and goofing can go wrong,
but yeah,
but I think that one of the things that
I've been fascinated by is where did all
this madness come from?
And I increasingly am wondering whether
it comes from social and emotional
learning that started to be taught in
schools around emotional intelligence.
So this whole idea of eat q I think had
a lot to it,
but not all the bugs were worked out
because a lot of things that kind of are
in the neighborhood of bullying might be
actually intimacy building.
Right?
And so if something turns into some
super disgusting,
deadly hazing ritual,
we all say,
what the hell are you people doing?
But on the other hand,
if it's sort of three clicks back from
that line and it's,
you know,
there was mild discomfort.
We humiliate each other a little bit and
now we're friends for life.
Um,
then you know,
the fear of the hazing ritual gone wrong
may actually stop people from ever
actually making the really deep bonds to
last a lifetime.
Well,
isn't that like everything else?
Some people are good at things and some
people suck at it.
So some people are good at being silly
with their friends and some people go
too far.
I mean,
you,
you experienced that.
Like I've had friends who experienced
that where they do a podcast on the
podcast,
they fuck with each other,
right?
And they'll have someone come up to them
that they don't even know right off the
street and immediately say something
like,
ruthlessly insulting to them.
And I like,
what the fuck?
And uh,
yeah man,
you do that shit on your podcast all the
time.
It's like,
okay,
you're doing it wrong.
I don't know you.
We're not friends.
We're not bonding here.
You're walking up and saying something
mean calling someone about Fatso.
Exactly.
Yeah.
It's just not good at it.
And oftentimes that's a,
some sort of a sign of social
intelligence,
a lack of social intelligence,
a lack of.
I mean,
who knows what's going on in their home
that might just be bad information from
parents and they're growing up in this
environment of a very low level social
skills.
And now what we're doing is,
I mean,
I think that you're spot on,
we're now going to try to readjust
everyone around our weakest players.
Right?
So now the idea is that because that can
be said in a horrible way,
we're not going to let anyone say
anything remotely adjacent to it.
Yeah.
You can't do anything that would be a
precursor to it.
So you're just going to say,
well,
you see that little patch of bad cells
over there,
we're going to cut off your leg,
uh,
in order to stop that cancer.
It's just like,
couldn't we do something a little bit
more surgical?
Well,
and also there's some things that
you're,
there's a reason why we have this
instinct to mock things because people
get out of La and then they demand too
much goddamn attention and they become a
problem.
And this is a,
I think,
I believe this goes back to hunting
parties and hunter gatherers were the
one person who just wanted too much
attention.
Like you,
you're fucking it up for this group
effort.
And that's Kinda what happened socially
when people claim these very ridiculous
victim statuses,
you know.
And there was
a picture that I put up on my instagram
a couple of weeks ago of this guy.
He had this crazy makeup on and he had
this ridiculous description of himself,
like non binary queer that also
identifies as a Muslim.
And he was talking about quantum physics
and quantum physics.
Got helped him appreciate his queerness
and I looked at that.
I said,
okay,
maybe,
or maybe you're just fucking crying out
for attention,
and all I wrote was a makes sense,
definitely doesn't seem crazy and people
got mad at me for that.
For something so obvious.
I looked.
I just peered into the fucking deep
dungeon.
That is the comment section for a moment
and I saw people like you would think
that the people that are most
susceptible to suicide,
you would leave them alone,
but you're cruelty is you know you're
exposing your cruel to like,
listen,
that's silly.
That guy needs better friends.
Your friends are you going to tell you
you're silly.
You got crazy makeup.
Have you seen Scott?
You have a photo.
Look at this British Iraqi gay,
non binary and also identify as Muslim.
Listen,
you need too much goddamn attention.
That's all I'm saying.
I'm not saying you're a bad person.
You should kill yourself.
You shouldn't be queer.
Be whatever you want to be,
but if you're going that hard,
that hard to define yourself like that
is needy as shit.
That's fucking annoying.
Your
point,
your point is that you have to titrate
the negative feedback,
right,
so what you did was you gave them a
small dose and say,
look,
you might want to course correct a
little bit,
but the idea that there's any course
correction that you're not sitting there
celebrating this.
Right.
Well,
that's.
That's the thing.
Yeah.
You're supposed to celebrate it.
I'm supposed to celebrate so many
things.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what?
You can celebrate it.
That's okay,
but you shouldn't get mad if I go,
oh,
that might be a little nuts because it's
obvious little nuts.
It's a little nuts to paint your face
with glitter.
It's a little nuts.
If that was just a regular person who's
like,
hi,
I work at JC Penney.
My name is Wendy and this is what I like
to wear on my face.
Like,
okay,
Wendy's a crazy bitch.
Look at Wendy.
Go look at Wendy.
Look at her face.
What is she doing?
I don't know,
man.
She got fucking crazy glitter and our
hairs.
15 different colors a little bit.
Okay.
Let's look at it this way.
I have this weird thing which sometimes
is called Makilah phobia,
the fear of cosmetics.
Really?
Oh Man.
Lips.
What?
Con?
Like smoking,
smoking.
No.
Fake eyelashes.
Well,
is the thing is,
is that sometimes they look somewhat
normal and then suddenly it doesn't
integrate and the person just looks like
they've got crazy stuff stuck to their
head.
Like you've got crazy stuff's stuck to
you.
Well,
that's how I perceive it.
Now here's the question.
I can't be in touch like they can't be.
Eric's got a problem with Makilah
phobia.
Never heard that word.
It's freaking me out.
It has to be a phobia that it has to be.
Eric can't accept people who wear
makeup.
And my question would be from first
principles,
how do you tell who to have sympathy
with?
Because this has been somewhat
debilitating for me.
Really?
Yeah,
sure.
So it's been a real issue,
like you've struggled with.
It struck.
We have.
You struggled with the feeling or
struggle with the fact that you have
that everybody actually experienced,
if you remember Tammy,
Faye Bakker,
right?
So she was famous for freaking people
out because she had no concept of how
much a hangup is too much,
is too much.
Now what if somebody looks normal and
then you turn around and suddenly there,
Tammy Faye Bakker and you never can
predict when that's going to happen.
So that's an interesting question about
do we accept the person who.
I don't know why I have this,
it's just that some thing in my mind.
Well,
because you're a logical person and
you're looking at this war paint that
people are putting on and you don't
understand the desire to do this,
but I do understand you do,
but you don't understand actually doing
it.
I don't understand why it looks normal.
Like I have the feeling that other
people,
it looks very different than the way it
looks to me.
Right?
Well,
they've just accepted it.
Maybe sometimes I accepted and then
suddenly,
you know,
I shake it.
It's like you're shaking out of the
movie,
like you see a movie where the suddenly
the Mike is visible from the top,
uh,
what's going on here?
It's a movie,
it's a movie and and that,
but anyway,
we all have these weird quirks.
The question is with whom should we be
sympathetic and with whom do we do?
We say,
well,
you're being judgmental with me.
It's a women's shoes that have gigantic
heals.
Those stilettos that they could barely
walk in.
That one freaks me out.
It freaks me out because I see women
walking in.
I'm like,
this is so crazy that this is a choice
that you are.
I mean,
I can't imagine I'm paranoid.
I guess maybe I've seen too much
physical conflict.
I can't imagine wearing something that
would physically compromised me to the
point where I literally can't run away
because you can't run away and those
things,
and if you're in like stilettos,
like these little things that you walk
around in and your feet are all smushed
in your.
You're basically doing tiptoes
everywhere you go and you fuck.
You have to be killing you by the end of
the night.
Right?
Right.
You're not running away.
This is a wolf chasing you or some shit.
If there's something going down,
you're not.
You're not getting away.
It's just,
it's a weird,
like the desire to lengthen your legs
and to give this graceful appearance
called Lordosis behavior.
Large doses or doses learning so much
today.
So high heels were originally developed
for men to appear taller.
I'm not sure if it was too pure,
taller only,
or if it was for writing.
I can't remember.
Maybe for a lot of people don't know.
Cowboy boots.
The reason why they slip on like that is
when the horse box and takes off your
boots fall off.
They're supposed to.
I didn't know that.
Yeah,
that's the whole idea behind the reason
you slip on and slip off and they have
that heel is that wouldn't heal that
he'll slips into the stirrups.
So when you get when the Horse Bucks,
you don't want to get dragged on.
You wanted that shit that just fly off
and then you're on your back going,
Oh look at that horse go and then you go
pick up your boots because they've
fallen off.
The fucking horse is gone,
but at least you're alive.
Oh,
that's the expression.
He died with his boots if you.
Yeah,
if you get.
Well,
not really,
I think that's like a gunfight type
deal,
but I think if you get dry,
I mean if you get dragged,
horses are gonna,
run over rocks and shit,
you're done.
People die all the time that are wearing
regular shoes that shoved their feet in
the stirrups and then you're stuck.
That's why cowboy boots come off like
that.
Yeah.
I remember when I used to ride horses,
we'd have the guy leading the trail
would like take us up to a gallop and
suddenly say emergency dismount.
It was really terrifying.
Yeah.
And you know,
you'd have to do it at speed very,
very quickly.
But I think that high heels got taken
over by women because a lot of the
things that we claim that we like about
heels,
that is the,
uh,
I do it for height,
like the way it makes the leg look at
probably secondary to the curvature of
the back and the way in which that is
typically a associate associated with
sexual receptivity.
So it's that particular posture that the
heel keynotes.
And so the way I read it is that the
cost of the heel is part of the
communication.
In other words,
I'm willing to do something that is
clearly not comfortable or for my
benefit in any other way.
So much so that you can tell that I must
be interested in sending a signal 100
percent.
Yeah.
So,
so the.
Well,
but you have to deny the signal to.
So part of the signaling is to say,
Oh,
these are actually my most comfortable
shoes.
They always say that girls are
hilarious.
They're so comfortable.
These are so comfortable.
Right?
Like how is that even possible?
Those aren't crocs.
Yes.
But,
but,
but the deception has to be part of.
Now I'm like,
picturing
that was really weird.
Well,
the deception has to be.
You have to,
you have to decide that you're not
ridiculous.
Shared deception.
Yes.
Because as the guy,
I have to say,
oh,
that's so interesting.
Yeah.
But that's a lie.
Well,
we're all lying,
but it's mutually understood is a lie.
Yeah.
But when the girls are,
girls could say these are so comfortable
because they're not killing them because
they've accepted a higher level of pain
tolerance with footwear than men have.
Like if I had a just jam my feet into
something pointy.
Like some point.
Yes,
Spanish dancer type shoes.
It would hurt after awhile you ever wear
a tie?
I hate those things.
So that's some kind of uncomfortable
thing that we do to ourselves as men.
Well,
I used to have to wear one when I drove
limos.
I think.
Well I've definitely worn one since
then,
but very rarely,
very rarely can kill you pretty easily
with a tie.
Like if someone has a tie on and I grab
a hold their Thai boy,
unless you're a lot bigger than me,
I might kill you.
Got a hold of your tie ties.
A hard thing to shake loose.
It's really strong like you could you.
A good tie is not going to rip.
Someone gets a hold of your tie at the
not just twists and holds onto you.
All they have to do is hold onto you,
grab an arm,
and just grab,
wrap their legs around you and hold onto
that ty.
You're a dead man.
Your debt.
You're.
You're giving them a weapon.
Heal you all the time.
All right,
you've convinced me no more ties.
I just grabbed that and just look and
twist.
You don't have much time,
men,
you,
you don't have much time to get this arm
off.
Your such a UFC.
Have to figure out.
It's a Jujitsu spin.
[inaudible],
UFC.
You don't wear clothes,
but to be able to grab a hold of
someone's clothing like like a person
with a leather jacket.
If you're talking shit and you have a
leather jacket on,
you're with a guy who knows judo.
You are beyond fucked.
You don't do this.
This guy might as well have cannons
coming out of his body like you're.
You're doomed.
You're 100 percent doom.
He's going to grab that leather jacket
and basically this handles and he's
gonna throw you up in the air and he's
going to hit you with the world.
The whole world is below it.
He's going to drive you into the world
and you're so fucked and you don't even
realize it.
Joe,
how often do you end up in fistfights?
Never.
Never,
man.
I don't know.
I don't want to have nothing to do with
that.
I just get away.
I would never want to get into
fistfights.
This is fascinating to me about this
sort of the world here.
It's always talking about fighting and
what can happen,
but just in in our world,
there's like almost none of this in,
you know,
relatively boring white guy,
middle age.
You ever go on Worldstar hip hop,
that Shit's all day everyday.
There's plenty of videos you most,
most of the time nothing happens,
but the one time when Shit does happen,
if you don't know how to defend
yourself,
you're really fucked.
This is.
This is true,
but then the thing is,
is that in all the practicing that you
do,
you're also exposing yourself to the
potential for injury.
Oh yeah.
So there's a question as to whether
you're safer.
If you spend all of your time in this
kind of,
well,
what if something happens?
I want to be prepared,
but the preparation for it is itself
potentially fairly hazardous.
That's unquestionable,
but isn't that just like the guy who
sits on the couch and never goes into
the woods because he doesn't want to get
tired.
I know it's very similar because like
here we are,
I'm 51 years old and um,
and it all works.
So even though I've been injured,
I'm right here.
Everything works like a.
But you also got of this shit fixed.
What if the UFC thing was like bold and
interesting when you were a young guy,
do you think you would have.
I would have 100 percent done it and I
probably would have a much harder time
having this conversation.
That's right.
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
So I think you hit the sweet spot where
you got the skills you've been in
training idiom,
you really know what you're talking
about and you're getting front row seats
but not actually having to have your
brain particularly take the pounding.
There's no getting away from that.
And that is the unfortunate reality that
every fighter accepts.
There's no getting away from that.
There's,
there's an absolute possibility,
and it's not just your head,
it's also your joints.
A big part is your back and your neck.
I know many guys that have neck
impingements and disc herniations and
fused neck disks and then nerve pinched
nerves or impinged to the point where
they have atrophy in their arms.
I know several guys who have that where
they have one arm that's smaller than
the other arm and it severely impedes
their ability to move and they used to
be world champions to guys that have
been on the show bus route and Pat
Miletich two of the greatest of all
time.
Both guys have one small arm in one
regular size arm because of neck
impingements who their nerves are
literally pinched down by all the
swelling and scar tissue and that
damaged discs.
Yeah.
Well since we became friends,
I started just casually looking at this
world and it's utterly fascinating.
I mean there's.
There's nothing like it.
Well,
did you Jitsu world?
I think you would.
There's two different worlds,
right?
There's the MMA world which incorporates
all the different martial arts,
and then there's the Jujitsu world and
the Jujitsu world.
I think you would find seek out.
Yes,
you would love it because it's basically
to call it chest is not quite fair
because it's more complex than chess.
There's much more going on.
Visa freedom are so high,
but it's also easier to win if someone's
better than chess because even if
someone is fairly competent in chess,
we'll take a few moves to beat them.
In Jujitsu,
if someone's fairly competent in the
other one is a master,
it probably crush your very quickly,
but the.
When you watch two really high level
guys trying to set each other up,
it's this crazy rolling exercise and
leverage and position and in the
knowledge of moves that Eddie Bravo
versus a crazy crazy.
Yeah.
It's hard to even know what's going on.
It's crazy.
If you don't know,
it's one of my more difficult challenges
of being in a commentator is when the
fight goes to the ground explaining to
people watching at home.
What he wants to do right now is get his
right leg over his arm and as soon as he
does that,
now that arm is stuck.
He's in trouble right now,
you know,
and like to try to explain that to
people so they can follow along.
Go,
oh,
I see,
I see.
And he's going to grab that.
He's arch arches back any tapped?
And people go,
oh,
and it gets people really excited about
Jujitsu because they see that and you
go,
oh,
this is like really complicated.
Like he's got,
there's like a dance he's doing.
The other guy's trying to resist.
But the first time I saw the gracie
breakdown of particular fights where
they've committed to memory every move.
Yeah.
It's like replaying the great games of
like morphy or Combo Banca chess and
you're just thinking,
wow,
that,
okay,
there's the evergreen game,
there's the moral game and that that to
me is fascinating,
but it's actually more interesting to me
in the UFC arena because of the fact
that that's only a component and that
it's.
What I didn't understand was how much we
could get close to unrestricted fighting
and still have people fairly dependably
survive with minimal obvious disfigure
disfigurements there is disagreement.
Would there are some.
We could even be safer if we eliminated
weight cutting.
The weight cutting is the number one
health issue in the sport in my opinion.
Yeah.
Number two is the brain damage and the
impact and the,
you know,
broken bones and things along those
lines,
but the number one is weight cutting
because it's so unnecessary.
It's such a,
such an issue that needs to be addressed
because these guys want to compete at
the highest weight possible.
So do you know how it works?
No.
Okay.
Say if you were going to compete in the
170 pound division,
but you actually weighed one 90,
which you would do is you would wait
until you would follow a pretty strict
diet,
keep your body weight in your fat a
certain level,
and then when it comes down to a few
days before you would dehydrate yourself
pretty radically.
Yeah.
And then rehydrate yourself
scientifically using the.
There's a bunch of guys like George
Lockhart guys who are experts in this
and then they'll give you the exact
right amount of nutrients right around
of potassium and zinc and they want to
replenish all of your electrolytes and
get you in a perfect balance,
but you're still compromised and if you
don't have a guy like a George Lockhart
or someone who's a real expert in
nutrition and understands biology and
can get you back into that position,
you're most likely gonna compete
compromised,
but you're going to accept that
significant compromising because you're
going to be a bigger person than the
person you're fighting,
but they also,
like in boxing in particular,
the vast majority of deaths have
occurred in the lighter weight divisions
and a lot of it is not just because of
the head trauma,
but because it's head trauma to someone
who's dehydrated.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
It's like it's.
It's.
It sucks and it's contrary to what
martial arts is supposed to be about.
Martial arts supposed to be about skill
for skill.
It's not supposed to be about cheating
and that cheating thing is like you're
dehydrating yourself.
It's like sanctioned cheating.
You're saying you're 170 pounds if
you're like,
if you say this,
the 170 pound champion and get on the
scale is one 93.
What the fuck's going on?
This isn't a 170 pounds.
Now frustrating if I want to meet you in
a different class like I wanted to fight
you my whole life,
but we're really separated.
Well,
you can lose weight the right way.
Look,
if somebody wants to compete at 170
pounds,
in my humble opinion,
they should actually weighed 170 pounds.
My friend Cam Haynes is a ultra marathon
runner and one of the things that he
does when he gets ready for ultra
marathons is he loses bodyweight,
but he doesn't have any body weight to
lose.
So he'll.
He'll burn 300 calories and eat 2000
calories and that's how he loses weight.
He lets his body eat itself so he gets
down to the sixties and that's when he
runs these gigantic long races,
like 240 miles.
But I know he's done this.
You can do this like you don't have to
dehydrate yourself,
but they choose to dehydrate themselves
because they replenish and then they get
much bigger when they get inside the
octagon.
When he's 65,
he's actually one 65.
That's just what he weighs and that's
the best way to run 240 miles,
so he does it through discipline,
but these guys that are it and it's not
their fault because it's already been
established.
It's a part of the sport.
It's been there for years and years and
years and it's.
It's sanctioned cheating and everybody
does it and it's the worst part of the
sport because it's really damaging to
your kidneys,
terrible for your organs.
Your body starts to shut down when you
do it too often and your body doesn't
want to lose weight anymore,
so it starts to really hold onto that
water and guys fall asleep and pass out
and bang their heads off.
Walls and fights get canceled like pro
championship level flights get canceled
because guys blackout and crack their
head off the wall and this is.
This has happened in the in the UFC
before.
It's just super,
super unnecessary and unfortunate and
part of it is because there's not enough
weight classes.
There's like,
you know,
there's 1:55,
then there's one 70.
The difference from 1:55
and one 70 is not just 15 pounds because
if you actually weigh 1:55
and this guys dropping down to one 70,
that motherfucker could be one 90 plus
and he's just figuring out a way to cut
weight to get down to there and that
happens all the time.
So you're,
you're dealing with,
you know,
it could be 25,
30 pounds difference between you two
guys if you're,
if you actually way with the weight
classes when you get into the octagon,
so people are forced to drop weight,
they're forced to go lower.
If they want to compete at a world class
level,
they're forced to take this extra risk
and it could be mitigated.
It could,
it could all be stopped by hydration
test.
The UFC could step in.
All the athletic commissions could step
in and say,
enough is enough.
You're going to fight it,
what your way and we're going to give
you more weight classes so you could
figure out what's the wait for you to be
best at and I hope it doesn't take
someone dying before they figured this
out because it's one of those things
that people have done like circumcision.
They've done it forever so they just
keep doing it,
but if they just started doing it
tomorrow,
people are like,
why did you cut that baby's Dick?
Are you fucking crazy?
Well,
I've always cut babies,
ticks.
I've been cutting babies.
Dick's for years.
Like this is right.
It's like a yiddish get used to it.
Well,
it's not just yiddish mean I'm Catholic.
My Dick are cut.
It's like practiced across the board
under the guise of being sanitary.
It's prevention of AIDS.
All these stupid reasons to cut dicks
like it.
Really,
it's just a tradition that doesn't make
any goddamn sense.
Now.
It's not the best analogy to weight
cutting
the cutting dicks.
I do want to pick up on an analogy which
I'm curious about.
So when you're trying to describe the
ground game,
yeah,
it's super tough for a lay audience
because the picture doesn't necessarily
match what you're seeing because the
layer of expertise makes a bunch of
random arm movements and head movements
and hip movements into something else.
We have the same problem in like math
and physics where everybody wants to
know what's going on with that thing.
And then when you have been listening to
like the physicists on your program,
I don't think you have many
mathematicians,
but it's so confusing to figure out how
to talk to the world about things that
people,
everybody wants to know about.
And I was just curious as if you saw a
parallel,
uh,
in those two things.
Those are certainly very high art forms.
Yeah.
I'm.
Sean Carroll has done a really good job
of trying to explain things.
Neil degrasse Tyson's done a really good
job trying to explain things.
I saw,
um,
the explanation of gauge symmetry
Lawrence Krauss on your show,
which is like from two to my way of
thinking when the most important
principles in the world.
I still have no idea what the fuck he
said exactly.
Well like,
well I read his book.
Yeah.
And after I read his book,
that was the number one question I had.
I said,
okay,
I need you to explain to me what is
gates symmetry?
What does that mean?
It's so weird that he didn't.
I don't think he expected you to just
bust it out.
Yeah,
I don't think so either.
That's it,
but I think that it's so hard to like,
okay,
here's one of my.
I will get back together.
Symmetry maybe.
But like when people say the universe is
expanding,
right?
What the fuck does that mean?
Every,
every smart person says into what?
Right.
You know,
like it's the universe.
What is it expanding into?
Right.
And where's it going?
And it,
it doesn't make any sense because the
linguistics of the universe is
expanding,
isn't really what the what.
So you're saying the matter in the
universe is moving outwards,
is that what the universe is expanding?
What it means is I'm,
the infinite universe is getting more
infant her.
No.
So first of all was that they.
Did you say that?
Yeah,
I was trying to be silly to sativa is
kicking in.
Yeah.
Um,
so if you think about this bottle,
right,
it's the slices of the bottle that are
expanding,
but if you think of the bottle is the
universe the bought the bottle isn't
expanding.
It's just the cross sections that are
And so that's what they really mean.
What they really mean is something like
the spacetime metric on space,
like cross sections has a,
it's volume for them when integrated is
higher or something like that.
Some,
some mathematical statement,
but the universe is expanding is not
helpful to me.
Like if I wasn't able to read the math,
I would say I don't get it.
Well,
I don't get anything quite honestly.
I'm not being self deprecating.
I don't get the Big Bang.
Yeah.
I don't get it at all.
Well,
okay.
Here's what somebody should tell you.
Okay.
Um,
there are two kinds of singularity's
when you try to solve Einstein's field
equations for gravity.
So gravity as a thing,
Einstein tells us pretty much,
uh,
what we think gravity is the curvature
of space and time.
And when we try to solve his equations,
we get these black hole singularities
which called swartz chilled
singularities,
and let me get this initial singularity
a which we associate back to the big
bang with the freedmen Walker Robertson
model in some.
Those singularities are indications to
us that we're not at the end of physics
and that Einstein's equations aren't,
there aren't the real story.
And so rather than sort of saying
they're a pretty good model up until
this point and then we kind of really
don't know what happened,
then we have the observational thing
that we would map to the big bang and
then we have the model thing that we
would map to the big bang.
And to be honest with you,
I'm pretty sure that are our models
don't make sense past a point.
And now we're having this conversation
past the point where we're pretty sure
they don't make sense.
That would be much more honest to me,
but because we have this desire to,
um,
to blow people's minds gratuitously,
and everybody wants to.
How did everything begin and where are
we?
Who are we in?
We want to sort of answer more of that
than we probably should.
Hmm.
That's an interesting way.
That makes sense.
Let me give you an alternate spin on
quantum mechanics.
Okay.
So typically people will say,
you know,
the mind blowing thing about quantum
mechanics is that it's probabilistic and
that is kind of mind blowing,
but if you actually say it differently,
you say,
look in classical mechanics like newton
stuff that we feel more comfortable
with,
you have good questions and bad
questions.
Like if you and I go hang out at the
beach and I say to you,
hey,
where's that wave concentrated?
At what point does that with wave live?
You look at me and say it's a wave.
It's not concentrated at a point.
It's all along the shore.
So as a classical physicists you to say
that's not a good question,
Eric,
and when I asked you a good question,
like how fast is that wave front,
moving along this trajectory of
something,
you can give me an answer and it's
definite.
So as long as you ask a good question.
In classical mechanics,
you get definite answers when you go to
quantum mechanics and you ask a good
question.
Uh,
technically that means that the state
vector is an observable of the,
her mission operator representing the
question.
Nevermind.
I'm funny.
Thing happens.
You get deterministic answers.
There's no probability involved
whatsoever.
So if I ask a good question in quantum
mechanics,
I have the same property that I,
I,
I do.
When I ask a good question in classical
mechanics,
I get a definite answer.
There is no probability when I ask a bad
question and quantum mechanics instead
of like classical mechanics says,
you know,
screw off,
I'm not answering that.
That's ridiculous.
It's a bad question.
Quantum mechanics,
as you really want to ask me a bad
question.
All right,
I'll give you maybe this answer and
maybe that answer and here's the
probability distribution that I'll
actually give you either of those two
answers and what's more,
I'll even kick it into the state that I,
that you asked about.
So for example,
if you ask where is that wave
concentrated?
So like let's say this is my coffee cup
and I drop a little drop in the center
of it,
that creates a circular way that
radiates.
And I say,
where does the wave concentrated?
Well,
at one second it hits the Coffee Mug.
Let's say it's a big coffee cup and at
one second after that it's concentrated
again in the center.
So that becomes a good question only
when the wave becomes really
concentrated in the center of the cup.
Right?
But if that wave where a quantum wave,
I could ask where is the way of
concentrated and with equal probability,
suddenly the wave will concentrate at
some point along the circle that
represents the wave,
right?
So what would your answer be then?
What the point would be a.
it'll concentrate at one of these points
around the circle at random,
with equal,
with equal probability,
and suddenly the wave will concentrate
randomly.
When I,
when it's a quantum question.
So this is why quantum mechanics is so
confusing.
Quantum physics are so confusing to
people because they hear,
they hear that and they go,
okay,
this is confused when in my head like
Jello.
Well,
that's the thing,
but the point of if I,
if I have a wave and I slow it down,
I can look at a wave and a coffee mug
and I can see that if I ask where is the
wave concentrated,
you would say it's concentrated at like
half an inch from the center of the cup
and say,
no,
not what ring is it concentrated or what
exact point that concentrated in exact
point,
but that wave in quantum mechanics which
is not concentrated at an exact point
behaves differently.
When I ask a bad question.
So the,
the point that I'm trying to get across
is good questions have exactly the same
properties in classical mechanics and
quantum mechanics.
There's no introduction to probability
theory.
The weird question is why is quantum
mechanics answering bad questions?
Well,
or maybe even weirder question is
not just why is quantum mechanics in an
adolescent state of understanding?
I mean,
it was part of the problem that they
don't know enough yet and they're trying
to like explain what they do know and
what they can prove on paper and for a
person like me,
like,
well,
what do you know?
And they're like,
well,
we know probabilities.
We know this,
we know that and a person like me who
doesn't have any studying and it just
goes up.
What does that mean?
Well that's,
that's great.
So like let's say we were having a
conversation about genetics and we were
looking only at the DNA and we didn't
see epigenetics in terms of like
methylation patterns.
Then you'd,
you'd shove everything onto DNA and
maybe you had no concept of like
development and the model would work up
to a point would explain why you have
blue eyes or Brown eyes,
but it wouldn't explain all sorts of
other things.
And so now then you over overdeveloped
that model.
So I think that what you're saying is
really Einstein's intuition,
which is.
I'm not saying I'm Einstein,
I'm not saying that this is wrong.
I'm saying this is incomplete.
And then when we finally get the answer,
we're going to say,
oh,
that's why we used to think of it in
those crazy terms.
So back to gauge theory,
gauge symmetry.
What the hell was that?
All right,
well,
here's the.
Here's the craziest thing.
Okay.
There is a very confusing visual image
of the fundamental unit that you need to
appreciate what gauge symmetry is all
about.
And uh,
I had Jamie loaded up under the tab
called planet hop and this is going to
hop pf a h,
o,
p,
f,
what the fuck am I looking at you?
Or looking at the most important object
in the universe,
what that looks like,
some trippy screensaver on your laptop.
Take another puff,
my friend because it's worth it.
This is what you're looking at is a
principle fiber bundle and it's in,
it is the earth.
Those are the continents.
That's the cool part about it,
which is this is very confusing to
figure out what you're looking at,
but it's finite.
In other words,
if we stay for an hour or two on this
and we actually answer all your
questions,
you will actually know what a principal
and bundle is and you will know the
arena in which gauge theory exists for
folks at home that are just listening
and they were.
What the fuck are these guys talking
about?
What is the name of this video?
Jamie video.
Not a video.
It's a small file on a page I typed in
planet hop and that was the first thing
that showed up on math dot Toronto Dot
Edu.
Okay,
so extended thing.
Planet h o p,
F for anybody wants to look at this.
If you're just listening and you have no
idea why I'm freaking out.
So this,
this was done by a friend of mine named
Drawer Barn Aton.
I actually coded the same thing up.
Um,
strangely enough.
Didn't do a brilliant job of coloring
it.
It looks amazing.
Motorola.
So okay.
What's you're looking at is a two
dimensional sphere that is the surface
of the earth where an extra circle is
included at every point on the surface
of that sphere,
which you're now visualizing,
and that extra circle,
which would be called the fiber,
um,
when you take the totality of all of
those circles together,
one for each point on the surface of the
sphere,
they create something called a three
sphere that is all the points that are
one unit of distance away from the
origin in four dimensional space.
So that three dimensional sphere is the
analog of a two dimensional spheres
sitting in three dimensional space.
So think about a caramel apple.
If you've ever made caramel apples,
you get a disk of Carmel and you wrap it
around the sphere.
That is the apical surface,
right?
So this is the three dimensional version
of Carmel wrapped around the three
dimensional,
a sphere sitting in four dimensional
space.
Now,
do you understand any of this,
Jamie?
I'm trying,
dude.
It's totally trippy,
right?
And so we're not going to get it
completely during this session.
However,
I think I lacked the tools.
I don't think so if that we lack the
time.
So the first thing is you are finding
out that one of your friends thinks this
is the most important object in the
universe and you've never even heard of
it.
Much less know that there's one visual
example.
What's a fuck?
How is this happening?
I know exactly.
It does look fucking crazy.
Well,
okay.
This is what was discovered in the mid
19 seventies as the connection between
mathematics and different,
what we call differential geometry and
the discipline of particle theory.
So two guys,
uh,
Jim Simons,
the world now,
the world's most successful hedge fund
manager and cn Yang,
a person who might arguably be the
world's first or second greatest living,
theoretical physicists had a lunch
seminar.
And they said,
why don't we figure out how do we talk
to each other?
And what they found out is they both had
developed a version of this picture and
independently,
independently.
So it was the Rosetta stone that
unleashed a revolution.
So when Lawrence Krauss was talking to
you about gauge theory,
he was saying things about chessboards
and you color it white and you color it
black.
Super confusing to me.
I would rather your people be confused
about an actual example of the object on
which we do gauge theory that you can
visually see [inaudible] right now,
if I started to tell you what gauge
theory is pretty simple.
So here's the.
Here's the description.
I never hear anyone say when you're
doing differential calculus.
I don't know if you remember
differential calculus.
Trying to figure out the slopes of
lines.
Instantaneous rise over the run.
So that always makes sense to people.
Okay.
I figured out how fast it's going up
versus how fast it's going across.
But a question arises which is where do
you measure the rise from?
So for example,
if I say,
what is the height of Mount Everest,
Jamie?
We'll say 30,
30,
5,000,
something like that.
Something crazy like that.
Well,
let's get an internet connection,
I guess.
What do you think it is?
I don't know.
I can't remember if I was to say it's
$35,000.
What do you think that it was?
Twenty nine.
Oh,
two nine.
Okay.
What's,
uh,
the highest was the highest one.
Is it k two?
K Two is second,
right?
Is it has ever the highest?
Yeah,
but okay,
so everest,
29.
Would you say 29.
Twenty nine.
Oh,
two nine.
Nine.
Above what sea level.
Whereas Mount Everest located the
Himalayas.
What does that,
what?
See?
Uh,
there's no ocean there,
right?
So like we snuck its above sea level and
there's no ocean.
So we start from the center of the
Earth.
Will we have this structure called the
joy,
which is the interpolation of sea level
as if sea level is.
If the earth was only ocean and there
was no tie in as if there's some sort of
a.
So we snuck in the reference level.
That's my point is,
is that we teach these kids to repeat
why it's 29,000
and change above sea level and there's
no C.
Right?
So that reference level is the magic of
gauge theory,
right?
Which is that we measured the rise over
the run based on a custom level,
so at a level that we all agree upon.
So for example,
let's imagine that you and I are in some
country experiencing hyperinflation,
right?
And I'm your boss and you say,
dude,
I need a raise.
I said,
well look,
I've told you I would hire you for,
you know,
10,000
dinars a month.
And you say,
yeah.
I said,
well,
your salary is constant.
I took the derivative of it.
I've paid you $10,000
last month,
10,000
this month.
So you're getting the same amount
derivative,
equal zero.
It's constant salary.
Now you have to come back at me in
calculus and you say,
no,
I don't like your notion of the
derivative because what you're doing is
you're measuring the absolute number of
dinars that you're paying me,
but what I want to do is I want to
measure it and purchasing power because
I'm losing money every month that you
don't increase my salary.
So I now come up with a version of the
calculus in which Mike salary is not
constant because it's being measured
relative to purchasing power rather than
absolute units.
That's gauge there is that you're
bringing in a reference level that does
the differentiation.
So you're measuring rise over run by
customizing the problem.
So these were two different applications
of the calculus that cheating employer
says,
I want to go with constant dnrs.
The gifted employees says not so fast.
I know gauge theory.
I want to use a custom reference level
which is purchasing power,
right?
So it's like sneaking the geoint into
Tibet to measure everest.
I've got my custom level.
It was.
This makes sense to you.
Yes,
it makes sense right now.
Explain it.
Say what he said.
We would need a new reference of what
we're.
You want to measure what the new
conversation to have like a flat level.
I guess it would be really difficult for
me to recall a day from now maybe we'd
know we'd might have recalled that might
pop up mushroom cap.
See what's up.
It's.
I'm still in reference to quantum
physics.
Like how you would use gauge symmetry?
Well,
but let's do it.
Let's look at some more cool stuff with
the visual cortex because everything
that we can do visually should inform
what we can do linguistically.
So you should push everything into the
visual realm that you can.
Uh,
do you mean by that?
Like,
well I just showed you the hop
vibration,
which is the only,
in some sense the only mature picture I
can show you have a principal vibration
in geometry or physics that is honest
and has the full complexity.
It's got a certain kind of nodded
newness to it.
It's got something that we would call
curvature and it is visualized and so
it would be better that we spent,
you know,
a day or two on this most important
object which we think reality is based
around and that you visually got
comfortable with it.
And then you said,
okay,
now tell me again what gauge symmetry
is.
And then instead of Lawrence talking
about this chessboard and the colors and
all this stuff,
by analogy,
you'd actually be seeing gauge theory
visually like I could program a computer
and have done so to show you visually
what a gauge theory is.
And that takes some time to sort of
understand what the trip he pictures
are.
But if let's bring up the escher
staircase
and Jamie has a nice wrinkle on this,
that instead of using MC escher
staircase,
he's got this animated guy who just
keeps going down.
All right,
now what's going on with those stairs?
Now the stairs are sort of an optical
illusion because obviously it can't just
keep going down.
But then you build these systems like
rock,
paper,
scissors.
What's the best thing to throw in rock?
Paper scissors?
Well,
it depends on what you throw.
but we should be able to agree that rock
is better than scissors.
Rock has better than says this paper's
better than rock,
right?
So you go around that thing and now the
point is that you get to like rock as
much better than rock.
Right?
And that seems crazy.
Now that can concept would be what we
would call Holland Omi.
The weird sentence.
Rock is better than rock because of that
going around the loop.
Why rock has better than rock?
I don't get it well better than
scissors.
Scissors is better than paper.
Paper's better than rock.
So by transitivity rock is therefore
better than rock because you went around
the loop and came back to rock.
It's like Mna.
Math.
Yeah.
Or if like if you're.
If you're changing a currencies and you
don't spend any of it because you keep
losing using your credit card,
by the time you come home you had more
money than when you left because the
exchange rates did some things so that
when you changed into each currency,
you somehow got richer.
But by saying rock is better than rock,
you're denying the fact they're exactly
the same.
Well,
no,
not.
You're not addressing the linguistic
linguistic fallacy.
Right?
So the idea that this system here,
so those stairs in engaged theory would
be these reference levels for the
derivative [inaudible].
And you can have situations where the
reference levels don't knit flatly
together.
Right?
And so by virtue of that,
we would say that the system has
curvature,
curvature.
Is the assuredness of,
of these better than transitive
statements what we're looking.
Yeah,
folks,
for people who just listening,
we're looking at,
if you've never seen those essure
etches,
those sketches,
they're very strange because what there
are is a bunch of staircases that appear
to always be going downhill,
even if one of them is above the other
one.
It's a very strange,
very strange.
And this one we're watching an animated
guy rolled down this staircase
constantly,
even though it really looks like somehow
or another,
it must go up somewhere,
but you don't ever see it going up.
But it's also a factor of the illusion
of perspective and how it's drawn and,
and playing games with lines.
Exactly.
But if you do this very weird
experiment,
which we didn't know about until the
late fifties called the aronoff Boehm
experiment.
If you run,
um,
a,
an electric current through a wire
that's insulated,
um,
it's,
it appears not to have any
electromagnetic field outside of the
installation.
However,
if you do some sort of quantum
interference experiment,
you can tell that there's current going
through because it affects the phage
phase shift,
let's say,
of an electron orbiting that insulated
electromagnetic system.
So nobody thought that that was going to
happen because they thought,
well,
it insulator would keep.
We thought the electromagnetic field is
what determines the shift in the
electronic,
but it's insulated so there is no
electromagnetic field to worry about.
It turned out that it wasn't the
electromagnetic field alone,
it was some previous geometric concept
which is called the electromagnetic
potential that determine something about
the phase shift.
So this escher staircase in the case of
electromagnetism,
it's like the photons are the analog of
those steps.
They're partially would determine the
derivative operators,
does reference levels and again,
in our discussion of the,
uh,
am I paying you the right amount and a
hyper inflationary economy.
So all of these things you're trying to
figure out,
well that's an optical illusion,
but that effect actually occurs in some
systems,
not as an optical illusion.
Yes.
Right.
So this weirdness,
I'm requires a fair amount in terms of
either study of math or learning
visualizations,
but there's no way to achieve it in my
experience with linguistic
communications.
Like all the stuff that gets said about,
you know,
the universe is expanding or let me tell
you what it gauge theory is and why
there's a reason it's confusing.
It's because it doesn't make any sense.
I see what you're saying.
Sort of.
But.
So this is,
this is like what fineman said.
If you think you know,
quantum physics,
you don't know quantum physics.
Well there's some of that like there's,
you know,
one of the most important things in the
world is this thing called a spinner,
like the electrons and the protons
correspond to things called spinners.
And the average person has no idea that
spinners exist.
What's more?
Spinners have a property that when I
tell it to you linguistically won't make
any sense.
Alright,
good.
Let's do this with coffee.
Hit me with it.
Okay.
So yeah,
thank you sir.
Perfect.
All right,
here's the problem.
Okay.
Hold Your Cup.
No sorry.
From the bottom.
And here's the first challenge without
spilling it.
Okay?
I want you.
And without readjusting your grip on the
bottom of your cup,
I want you to turn your cup 360 degrees.
No,
no.
Sorry.
Turn your fingers.
Should not change on the cup.
Turn the cup 360 degrees without
spilling it and try to take a sip.
Okay.
That didn't work.
Now without coming back,
how would you take a sip if I got it all
the way around that way?
Yeah.
Mr.
Jujitsu man would have to.
Wow.
I would have to help myself.
No,
no,
you're going to do it.
Alright,
you ready?
Okay.
Here we go.
You're going to go around the circle.
Three hundred and 60.
Okay.
Right now I'm screwed if I don't bring
it back underneath.
Oh,
I see.
So that system required 720 degrees of
rotation unexpectedly.
You just keep going.
Right.
Okay.
Now the idea that there are objects that
don't come back to themselves under 360
degrees of rotation but require seven
slash 20 is probably something you've
never thought about before in your life.
Right?
But without that,
you wouldn't have the poly exclusion
principle,
you wouldn't have the stability of
matter.
And this thing is called the Philippine
wind dance.
Jamie,
do you want to.
That's not very seductive,
Jeff.
It seems like some very odd ethnic
dance.
Yeah.
But like maybe you could do 11th planet
Jujitsu.
Here we go.
So this spinner is one of the coolest,
most important objects anywhere.
And it was discovered to be important in
physics by a guy named Paul Dirac.
Right?
It's fun.
Okay.
So this 720 theory
is entirely responsible for the world
that we live in.
This is so bizarre to don't know,
but in animation and nobody knows about
it,
right?
Like unless you're hanging out with
physicists,
they don't tell you that
electromagnetism has to do with the fact
that there's a secret circle at every
point in space and time that's invisible
to you.
They don't tell you that there's stuff
that requires 720 degrees of rotation.
They just say mindblowing stuff about,
whoa.
So what is happening in his 720 degrees
of rotation in the quantum world?
There is an object that is requiring
this just the way the cup arm system
requires 720 degrees of is this called a
spinner and that spinner is how we model
the electron,
Neutrino corks,
all that is spin oriel matter,
sir.
That's good.
Long pause and like it.
And what,
where does this fit in,
in our model of the universe?
Like what is the function of this?
Why is it there?
What is it,
how do we know it's there?
Well,
we know it's there because uh,
when dereck.
So there was this problem with like the
Schrodinger equation.
Schrodinger equation takes one
derivative in terms of the direction of
time it takes to derivatives in the
direction of all the spacial directions.
But because Einstein told us that space
and time are woven together for the
theory to be relativistic,
you need the same number of derivatives
of time as of space because space time
is sort of one kind of semi unified
object.
All right?
That means you either have to boost the
number of derivatives of time up to two
to match the two derivatives and the
directions of space where you have to
knock the two direct derivatives in the
spatial directions,
down to one derivative to get it to be
equal.
Now one direction gets you to something
called the client coordinate equation.
What Dirac did is he took a square root
of the client Gordon equation to get
these spinners.
So he had these numbers he didn't
understand at first that he was going to
get kicked into this world of spinners.
He came up with a square root equation
in which eight times be thought to be
numbers was not equal to b times.
That was equal to the negative of b
times a.
So it was like,
what two numbers when you multiply them
matter in which order.
There wasn't numbers,
it was matrices.
So this was one of the great insights,
you know,
rival Tine Stein in terms of the depth
of what it told us about the universe.
Most of us haven't really heard of Paul
to rock.
We don't realize that he has.
One of the three most important
equations in physics now in when you say
three most important,
important in how it's applicable to
everyday life or important and how it's
given us an understanding and quantum
physics or important.
How it's understand it's,
it's understanding is is significant.
Quantum physics,
we're talking about bedrock reality like
you and I are having a conversation and
if you're a matrix fan and what we might
call the construct.
Okay.
What is the construct made have made?
So the way I do it is I think of it as a
newspaper story.
There's where and when did it happen?
There was who and what was involved and
there's how and why.
Okay,
so we're in,
when is space and time clearly
the WHO and the what?
To me,
let's say the who is the spinoff aerial
stuff.
It's like electrons,
protons,
neutrons,
corks,
the stuff that we're made of and then
you and I are only able to see each
other because we're passing photons back
and forth which are forced particles.
They're not spinning royal.
They,
they come back to themselves after 360
degrees.
They don't require 7:20.
So this is sort of the,
you know,
if you were going to go to a play,
you'd have the,
the dramatic personnel of the play given
to you at the beginning.
So this is what this universe is,
it's a story about space and time in
wherein,
when about what is in that,
you know,
like who are the players and what
equipment are they using that's like
Bozo firmagon's and then there's the how
and the why,
which is the equations and the Lagrand
genes that govern the rules of play.
You know.
So for example,
if you and I,
you know,
start to go to the beach and uh,
we've got a ball and a net and you think
we're going to play volleyball.
And we actually sent me,
says,
no,
we're going to play Seapak tuck grow,
which is like volleyball played with the
feet in a martial art style,
which is awesome.
Yeah,
we showed a video on that recently.
Sleeves from Thailand or Bali there.
They're really good at amazing.
It's amazing.
It's like ballet,
martial arts,
soccer and volleyball happening.
One thing we should,
we should do this as a nation.
That's a different set of rules for a
ball and a net in two teams that you
could have done it.
One way is volleyball and you could have
done it another way,
a Seapak Tucker,
were you using your feet,
not your hands.
So those.
That's sort of the breakdown of what a
physics theory is.
You got to tell me where and when you
got to tell me what's in the game and
you gotta tell me what the rules are and
that's what this place is.
So theoretical physics is the most
interesting of all of these fields to
me,
not because it speaks to us about our
daily lives because it speaks to us
about,
well where are we?
Where is,
where is this thing taking place?
So it seems to me that there's a small
number of people like that are studying
this stuff that are.
They're getting passed biology,
they're getting past gravity,
climate change,
all these different variables that we're
constantly dealing with and they're,
they're getting to the very things that
make everything and what is it under the
wiring lift,
lift up the board,
what's going on in here?
Right?
It's like getting into a computer down
to the zero and one logic gates,
right?
Yeah.
So that thing.
We've got three or four equations.
We've got three or four different kinds
of objects in the system.
We seem to be and people are going to
not like what I'm about to say,
but screw them.
We seem to be almost at the end,
like these equations are so beautiful.
They're so tight that it's almost most
mysterious because it feels like this
thing like a movie that ended
prematurely.
How so?
Well,
when we found the Higgs particle at the
LHC,
there wasn't anything left that needed
to close to explain the system.
We know that there's dark matter out
there that we don't understand.
We know that there's dark energy out
there that we don't understand because
of astronomical observations,
but all the stuff that we know about
when you look at it and collided at high
energies and figure out what mutates
into what.
There's nothing missing anymore.
So it's like.
It's like you have got this odd thing
where everything got very,
very simple,
very unified,
and it felt like we were going to get
one or two more giant unification and
the whole thing would be tied up with a
bow and right now we just don't have
anything that is needed to close the
system.
So for example,
when you have radioactive carbon decay,
um,
what you see is that one of the neutrons
flips into being a proton and it spits
out an electronic when it does that,
right?
So it's like,
it's like a trans nucleonics.
It shifts what it is.
Okay.
That electron doesn't carry off enough
energy to explain how energy would be
conserved.
There was something missing.
So this guy,
Wolfgang Pauli said,
I bet there's a particle that's neutral
so we can't see it.
We won't leave a track in a cloud
chamber.
It won't have any effect that we can see
electromagnetically,
but it's carrying away some of the
energy because I'm not going to give up
on conservation of energy just because
this particular process doesn't seem to
conserve it.
And sure enough,
there was the sneaky particle that was
spiriting away,
some of the energy of the system that
couldn't be seen because it didn't
interact electromagnetically and it
didn't interact according to the strong
force.
The only thing you could use to trap it
would be the weak force.
The weak force was so weak.
That was very hard to see it.
Okay,
well,
there's no new tree that I know have
left to find.
There's no thing that's missing in our
standard model and I'm just not
satisfied.
Nobody's satisfied that the play is
over.
Why would the play be over?
Just because we've discovered all the
neutrinos?
Well,
no,
it's that we had an easy job when there
was stuff that was missing and then you
just hypothesize.
I bet there's some invisible thing
that's carrying away some stuff.
Let's go look for something that's hard
to see.
So they find it.
And so they'd find the higgs.
So they find the higgs,
they find the neutrinos,
they find torque glue on plasma.
And a lot was going to go there.
But I was going to say that they found
like alternate generations of matter,
so you and I are made out of the first
generation of matter,
but there could be alternate Joe Rogan
made out of second generation or third
generation.
We don't know of any generations beyond
these two.
Hold up.
Yeah.
What are you talking about?
So like the electron has,
it has a relative called them yuan that
behaves exactly like the electronic,
except it's heavier and the uptown,
the up and quarks that make up protons
and neutrons have relatives called
strange quirks and charmed corks.
So there's like a second copy of Lego
that has all the same properties as the
first copy of Lego,
except it's at a different mass level,
which is denser,
but it's almost identical copy.
And nobody wanted this thing.
So the famous jokes there was this guy
is a door robbie who was like a,
you know,
kind of an ethnic Jew in,
in,
uh,
in New York.
And when they found the second
generation of matter,
he responded as if it was a group of
people at a deli.
And he said,
who ordered that?
You know,
and so that's,
that's the joke.
And physics who ordered that?
Nobody knew there was a second
generation.
And then like,
then they hit us over the head,
you know,
there's a third one too.
Everybody's just like,
what?
Why,
where are these things coming from?
So the fact that you don't know this,
like what a profound disconnect that
you're having all these physicists on
the show.
And these are the basic secrets that
were,
these are rock solid,
these aren't,
this isn't speculative multi-verse.
String theory will move Schrodinger's
cat stuff,
you know,
this is like,
this is ground truth and we don't know
it and we don't know it because nobody
will show you a picture of the
vibration.
Or there's a concept called the group,
which is how we think about symmetry
that no mathematician or physicist can
go a day without talking about groups
almost.
And we act as if it doesn't need to be
taught in high school.
Like it's too.
It'll blow your mind.
We're not going to teach you.
The groups even exists.
So we built the professional version of
the subject around objects that we don't
even tell you exist when you're studying
in school.
So if you think about the portal story
in childhood,
there's the story about either it's a
rabbit hole or a looking glass or a
wardrobe or platform nine and a half or
whatever these things are.
I don't know what the Harry Potter
version of it,
but how do I get from the world that I'm
in to this new amazing world and even
find out that it's there.
And that's what I think theoretical
physics has failed to do.
It hasn't built a portal for most people
to even understand what the issues are.
What are the objects?
What is the game?
How close are we to understanding what
existence itself is,
which I think we're very,
very close.
And the square root.
This was,
I was going to say before about Derok is
like the most profound object and
mathematics to me.
And the reason is is that when I ask you
what is the square root of negative one,
that is a question that can be posed
entirely within the familiar.
So the real,
the real numbers,
you're comfortable,
you know,
you owe money,
you have money.
So I need plus plus one and minus one
square root and understand what w,
what times itself equals my number.
And when you say what's the square root
of negative one,
there's no answer inside of the real
line,
but there is inside of this extension
called the complex numbers.
And so it's like you're in flatland and
you're trying to figure out is there
anything beyond flatland.
So the great thing about the square root
is it's a question you can ask in
flatland that gets you out of flatland
teases.
You confuse the shit out of me.
Are you with this?
I understood that part of it.
Yeah,
because I understood that part.
The complex numbers thing got weird when
you.
Okay.
Algebra.
So when I.
So when I'm taking like rotations of the
Coffee Cup where my arm isn't involved,
right?
I say okay,
is there a square root of that rotation?
Like what does that even mean?
Dude?
All right,
well now I put my arm into the system
and my arm plus Coffee Cup gives you
spinners like,
oh dude,
I did not even know that spinners were
here.
I did not know that any object required
720 degrees of rotation.
So the cup arm system,
we just exhibited it.
You don't need to learn Clifford
Algebra's or all of the extra jazz that
would get you to spinners
mathematically,
but you need to figure out how do I
discover the war,
the hidden world.
Think about this from the perspective
of,
of like Iowasca somebody takes Iowasca
and they have no idea that their brain
is capable of this alternate state or
Lsd or five Meo dmt.
All of these things are like panic rooms
in the mind where if you lived in a
house for 20 years,
you think you know your house and then
one day you pull an old musty book off
the shelf and suddenly the bookshelf
swings open,
you know?
And I was like,
holy crap,
there's like a second home inside of my
home.
Well,
that's a lot of what psychedelics,
psychedelics are like square roots.
Um,
in that their portals,
they can get you from the place that you
know into a place that you never
imagined could exist.
Do you think that the teaching of groups
and a lot of these concepts in
highschool would facilitate a better
understanding of it from the general
public and adulthood and the Gal and it
would.
What do you think is the resistance to
this?
It's just too complex or not applicable
to jobs,
you know,
is that the idea behind it is not
something that you use in everyday life
so that it's just too weird to think
about the fact that there's cousins to
the electron that are fat and
a much worse than this bodybuilder
cousin to the.
You want to bulk up and get made that
have strange quirks.
One of your cousins is made out of lead.
No,
I think it's much worse than this.
I think that first of all,
people are terrified of just how smart
children are and the differences between
children have to be buried.
So some children are graded abstraction
and a lot of the kids were great at
abstraction or learning disabled
according to the teaching system.
Now,
I personally think that most learning
disabilities have a particular type are
actually teaching disability.
People don't know how to teach the
smartest kids and groups and things.
You're going to lose some people because
of the level of abstraction,
but you're going to get other people who
have never been able to buy a base hit
and mathematics suddenly start over
performing.
So the problem is that when you teach
this stuff,
it's very disruptive to notions of the
hierarchy.
Have you
thought about what are the causes of
these different levels of perception?
Is it education?
Is it genetics,
is it environmental?
Is it some sort of a chemical balance of
the mind?
Like what?
What do you think causes people to be
more perceptive to some of these
concepts?
It's a good question.
So the thing I just showed you with the
planet earth in a way that you've never
seen it before.
I know of only two people who've ever
created that image.
I'm one of them.
Drawing Barden Aton is the other,
maybe there are many more,
but I've never heard of or met them.
The number of people first of all know
what the hop vibration is,
I would guess is really deeply know it.
It is a few thousand people in the
world,
so if none of those people are gifted at
trying to visualize or none of them
care,
none of them program computers,
the number of people who could present
that to the world is so small.
It's such a tiny priestly class that
your odds of getting anyone figuring out
how to make this understandable are very
small.
So we're talking about a very small
priesthood,
most of whom are too busy trying to do
new research,
to want to care,
to communicate.
Many of whom are not gifted
communicators.
Many of us realize that we don't fully
understand these things.
I mean like I can.
I can show you spinners mathematically
on a page,
but if you asked me in my darkest
moments,
do I believe that man really knows what
spinners are?
I don't think so.
This,
there's all this stuff that to me looks
like the monolith in 2001,
it's just too freaky,
comes out of nowhere and it's at the
core of reality.
Like if you really want to blow your
mind,
look at a tiny number,
tiny collection of these objects,
a principal fibrations spinners,
exceptionally groups this eight,
248 dimensional monster.
This,
uh,
what is that?
There's a 248 dimensional set of
cemeteries,
which seems to live only to be the
symmetries of itself where everything
else seems to live to symmetry,
tries something else and Nope,
this might have to spark that joint back
up again.
Let's do that.
You know,
there's this thing called the tits Fred
and fall magic square after this guy
named Chuck teats.
And um,
these guys,
uh,
figured out how to generate these sets
of symmetries of dimension.
Fifty to 78,
133 and 248.
We don't know why they're there.
They're like plot of Pi and a kid knows
of the mathematical world.
They're just different.
They don't seem to relate to anything
else that we,
that we know yet,
and that's what's so fascinating about
them and these are discovered by people
that are trying to figure out the nature
of reality.
They're discovered by people trying to
find more of these bizarre equation.
Who's who's discovering these in what's
the impetus?
Like what?
What is will you ask?
Very natural questions like you've
probably seen you ever played dungeons
and dragons as a kid?
Luckily.
No.
Okay.
While you were beating people up,
stop it.
I've seen one video anyway.
You had these die,
right?
Yeah.
Like the cube die.
The tetrahedral die.
What does this shaming pattern beyond
space time?
This is my eight d surface parents.
My Arch Nemesis when I was telling the
story last time.
Sober October.
Yeah,
Garrett Lisi.
Bobby took me out into the jungle to
meet this sort of differential geometric
warlord who lives in the north of Maui
and the jungle farming.
Yeah.
Well you don't remember this.
I do now.
Yeah.
You cut off my story,
man.
Santa.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
That's all right.
Go for it.
Here we are again.
Put that back up.
So whoa,
what is that?
Well,
this is,
this is based on the eight dimensional.
I'm almost certain it's gonna be based
on the eight dimensional root system.
So inside of the 248 dimensions,
there's an eight dimensional donut
called a tourists,
like an eight tourists,
and it generates this pattern and that
pattern in some sense in codes,
the instructions for building the 248
dimensional object.
So somebody probably pushed an eight
dimensional thing into two dimensions
for your viewing pleasure.
And does this accurate,
like when you're looking at this,
this image that we're seeing,
does that make sense to you?
I mean,
I could make,
I can relate it to things that make
sense to me.
If the idea is,
you know,
can I look at it the way I'd look at a
barcode and say,
oh,
tied unscented.
No,
I have no idea.
But um,
but this is an accurate representation
if you looking at it in two dimensions.
Yeah.
So what,
what I'm,
what I'm trying to say is you don't even
know to worry about this pattern,
right?
Because you've never heard that these
things exist,
and this is like the closest that we
come to,
you know,
genuine mysticism where we have these
objects.
If there are aliens,
they know about ie eight because the
eight or the aliens one ea does the
alien.
I've been,
I mean,
I,
we'll go to this later.
I don't want to interrupt your story
again,
but I have an idea.
So what I'm,
what I'm trying to get at is this is the
majesty and mystery of being a
mathematic mathematician or a physicist.
These findings.
So if I was to say about dungeons and
dragons,
you're given these dice where the normal
day is always a cube,
but the platonic solids,
you can have an octahedron tetrahedron,
Dodecahedron,
icosahedron,
all these things.
There's an analog of those five platonic
solids in the next dimension up.
So I think they're called convicts
polytopes.
So each one of those objects has an
analog one dimension up,
but was found out in the late 18
hundreds that there's a new platonic
solid and dimension for called the 24
says you want to bring up the 24 cell
and find an animated video of somebody
rotating this thing.
So like this is something that Plato
knew nothing about.
We don't really understand what it's
doing there in four dimensions.
These are like communications from uh,
the cosmos.
So this is like when Jodie foster was in
the movie contact and they were getting
them signals about how to make the time
machine maybe or the portal machine.
Yeah.
But this is on this stuff just doesn't
come with an instruction manual.
So part of it is you can prove that
these things are there
and you don't know why they're there and
some of them touch everything and some
of them have yet to touch almost
anything.
And it's like a communication from pure
design that there is so much beautiful
structure and so much grace in the
universe that we're just,
what the fuck is this doing here?
What is it?
Right,
well what is everything,
right?
What is the whole thing?
No,
I mean look,
if you accept three dimensional space,
um,
or let's say this glass right?
If you accept this glass,
I understand that a circle can spin the
glass.
The Circle circles worth of symmetries
tells me what to do to spend the last.
That's not that confused,
right?
Why is there something that the analog
of a circle where a circle I would call
one dimensional because it's got one
degree of freedom.
This thing is 248 dimensions and it
doesn't seem to live to symmetry.
Tries it in the jargon.
We would say it doesn't have a,
a,
a defining representation of lower
dimension.
So normally you have something of low
dimension and you say what are its
symmetries?
Symmetries are of higher dimension.
This thing seems like the first thing it
wants to symmetries as itself.
So it's kind of self referential.
It's kind of onanistic.
So it's like a zero point of creation.
That's poetic language and I would
groove on that after 11:00
PM,
but I wouldn't call it that right now.
I would say I was trying to pick
somebody up,
hey,
zero point of creation,
right?
That's a sexy word.
It's a sexy way of describing it,
but like if we were saying the big bang
existed and that means some point in the
history of the universe,
it was this really tiny thing and it
decided for whatever reason something
happened and it became this enormous
thing.
Sure.
Possibly enormous thing and it had.
There had to be a point where it
started.
Right,
but so what I would say is we can
competently take that story back to a
and then we have to say we don't really
believe that we have any insight beyond
that point,
but people want to go there anyway.
We absolutely know that it was tiny,
small,
like a smaller than the head of a pin.
The whole thing.
I'm always uncomfortable saying the
settlement.
You can,
you can say consensus.
You can say a lot of stuff about very
early,
very small and it could.
That could turn out to be wrong
in a possibly long ago,
14 billion years ago in our minds.
As far as tough for a guy like you
mathematics,
you see it on your numbers and paper.
It all computes.
You see the numbers.
Fourteen dollars billion is a number
that makes sense for sure.
But conceptually like for a dummy like
me,
14 billion is like if I really,
if I'm being honest,
do I do I really have an accurate
understanding what?
14 billion but,
but it's uneven Weinberg doesn't feel
$14 million either.
Right.
But you know,
100 yards is 100 feet,
100 yards.
I'm like,
that's too far to shoot a bow.
Like you got to get a little closer to
you.
So you have some,
you have some kind of an intuition pump.
Well,
you know,
distance.
It's a rational distance that you see on
a daily basis.
One hundred yards is a long distance.
A mile gets a little weird.
Like is that a mile away?
How far is that?
Oh,
it's six miles away.
Wow.
I didn't think it was that far.
Right?
Like there's,
there's weirdness in distance,
right?
But when you get to a hundred and 40
million miles,
okay,
I give up,
but you get to 40,
get fatigued,
get fatigued by that stuff that other
people get energized.
Like,
yeah man,
you have no idea how long ago that it's
humbling,
right?
But then there's the concept of
infinite,
like this is one of the things that
Krauss said,
or maybe it was Sean Carroll that said,
it's really not that we know that we can
see 14 billion years ago,
it's like,
but that's just as far back as we're
capable of seeing right now.
And even if we did go further,
the light is actually moving slower.
Like you wouldn't be able to see it.
Right,
right,
right.
So you have this thing about what the
spacetime metric,
which is sort of how things are,
feel like they're moving apart.
You know,
Einstein said four degrees of freedom
plus rulers and protractors equal space
spacetime,
right?
So a spacetime metric is a collection of
rulers and protractors.
So I can do length and angle,
including lengthen the time direction
and that generates a derivative
operator,
which we talked about before,
which is rise over run relative to
accustom reference level.
The customer reference levels generate
the staircase that we did and that
generates the curvature tensor which
generates gravity.
So strangely with all of this kind of
like woo woo stuff that we've been
doing,
we just came to a much better
description of what theoretical physics
actually looks like.
It's four degrees of freedom,
plus we're losing
protractors gives you derivative
operators with customer reference level.
The customer reference levels don't knit
together.
That leads to an escher staircase.
The degree of this is the curvature
tensor.
The curvature generates the gravity,
which is what's keeping you and I in our
chair.
I really appreciate that.
You're understood.
You're explaining this in a way that you
hope that someone can understand.
Well,
I'm not afraid,
I'm not a physicist,
but you're explaining it very well.
The problem is for someone like me,
I lack the tools to put there.
I don't have enough open slots for these
concepts.
So it's like.
It's like if you were explaining to me
complex arguments in French,
but I didn't speak French,
so you were saying,
you know,
bones,
it means this and then you're explaining
all these other words and then you throw
it all together.
I'm like,
what?
And then it's cultural references and
you have to deal with the fact that
there's some historical precedent to
certain types of behavior that I hadn't
taken into consideration because he's a
French people that have lived in this
way.
Oh whoa.
Okay.
But look,
look,
that's nothing compared to what you're
trying to.
Let's drop some.
Uh,
so,
so you do this thing about like,
well for meathead,
like me,
I'm definitely a meat head.
Stop it.
Listen,
I know me better than you know me.
That's true.
But you're also less honest than you
think on this particular topic.
It's part of your chart that,
look,
when we hang out,
we hang out usually in a comedy club or
at somebody's house,
right?
We don't say,
hey,
we're going to take the afternoon off
and we're actually going to learn
theoretical physics.
Right?
Right.
So when I went to a,
I did stand up for the first time,
as I told you in Arizona,
was there.
Oh,
it was insane.
It was crazy.
Yeah.
You try and explain fucking corks to
people.
It'd be.
There'd be some real humor in that.
If you could boil it down.
Three quirks.
Go into a nuclear.
Yeah.
There's like a way to do it.
I don't know.
There's a way to do it.
Okay.
Well,
the who was the guy who did the.
Some guy was doing.
He was praying,
Cowen was doing quantum jokes.
What was he saying?
Do you remember?
I forgot.
He just.
He had a bunch of words that he did
very,
very quickly and it kind of hung
together.
I was like,
wait,
what?
Yeah,
that sounds like Brian.
he reads a lot,
but it's a clever boy.
When I,
when I had to do my 10 minutes of
Standup,
man is that craft?
It's deep.
It's hard because you have to.
It's not just like telling jokes at a
party.
It's really.
You have to measure the way the
audiences laugh comes whether you're
taking them along or you going to divert
all,
all sorts of things that I never thought
about before.
Do you know how you feel when you talk
about the hop thing that it's a part of
everything?
It's one of the most important things
and yet very few people know what it is.
Maybe a thousand people understanding on
the whole world.
What's odd is that number is probably
identical to the number of legitimate
professional standup comedians in the
world.
That's why when I say legitimate,
I mean someone who can craft a new hour
every two years.
It does netflix specials who headlines
all over the country.
It's small,
good,
traveled all over the world and do
standup.
It's an small number
of humans.
Not only that.
My guess is that the number of people
that you think are at the very top of
that craft,
like when I really think about who
really knows theoretical physics,
right?
It's tiny.
It's like fuck,
it's smaller than 50.
Yup.
Guys that I would
pay to see live or women that are paid
to see live,
it's less than
50th,
less than 50.
And so part of our problem is that all
of the stuff that humanity is developed
is often resident and a tiny number of
minds and I feel very vulnerable about
the theoretical physics has been faking
that it's in a healthy state for a long
time.
We are so vulnerable on the doorstep of
actually cracking this puzzle in my
opinion.
Um,
that's where our comparisons in because
pretty much anybody could do stand up if
you put enough time to it,
if you're silly,
if you figured out the craft,
but would you guys are doing is not just
really rare,
but also the,
the barrier for entry,
like the cost of entry is exceptionally
high.
Like you have to spend an inordinate
amount of time studying and
understanding this stuff just to get to
a base level of what you've been able to
explain.
You've been explained like some really
difficult concepts to the lay person
that must've taken you fucking eons to
learn and understand all your study of
mathematics and of geometry and have all
that.
But I'm an imposter.
How so?
While I'm not a physicist.
Right?
But you understand it.
Maybe don't practice physics.
No,
no,
no.
I understand it.
Well,
no,
it's something more audacious than that,
which is that,
um,
when you see a,
you know,
a 10,000
hours only sign a,
you know,
only those who've done their 10,000
hours can come in.
My middle finger goes up.
I'm like,
I bet it's not 10,000
hours or if it is 10,000
hours,
I'm willing to get 80 percent of the
juice in that orange with like 10
percent of the effort.
The 10,000
hours thing to me is a,
it's cute,
but it doesn't factor in for phenoms.
It doesn't.
There's a lot of people that come into
anything.
Whatever it is,
with some natural abilities that are
pretty undeniable.
Um,
you know,
that's a weird,
that's a weird equation.
But take,
take something very simple like the
harmonica.
Yeah.
Most people don't know that that sweet
blues sound on a harmonica comes from
not using it the way the manufacturer
said,
which is called straight harp and using
it instead the way African Americans
figured it out,
which is it's much cooler to base it
around a hole that nobody was expecting
to draw rather than for blow.
And that gives you a seventh chord.
That sounds like sweet blues music.
If you start giving us some of that
right.
I don't know how will work.
Okay.
That was.
You got to move,
but.
So what's the traditional way of using
it?
What would it sound like?
Wow.
I think that would be carmen pouring his
fuck boy.
People music.
Boring as fuck white people.
God Damn it.
Why people at Carmen's alright,
but look,
that's not my point.
Who knew when you get one of these
things as a party favor as a kid there's
somebody says,
Hey,
don't do that thing where you put your
mouth over it.
I'll sign it.
You know?
But who knew that that's the coolest.
This.
Yeah,
but the idea is that there's something
called tongue blocking.
There's something called cross harp and
there's something called the one four,
five progression with a scale that no
music teacher ever taught you in grade
school and piano.
All right,
so there's four secrets
and now suddenly the world opens up.
I mean,
when I opened for Jordan Peterson,
Dave Rubin invited me and they said,
why don't you play a minute worth of
harmonica at the Masonic Theater?
So for 2,500
people,
I became Dave Rubin's talking Harmonica
Monkey.
So I opened for Jordan Peterson.
I said,
rule number zero,
life is too short not to play the
harmonica.
Everyone should learn to play the
harmonica or know why they're not doing
it.
There's this great thing in the cal
Berkeley fight song will win the game or
no?
The reason why if you don't play the
harmonica,
it's so nice.
It's so simple.
So few people do it.
They're so small.
Number of secrets.
You have to have a reason because I can
feed myself.
I can.
I can get housing,
shelter,
I can meet people anywhere in the world.
All I have to do is carry around a piece
of plastic with some metal on it or you
can be annoying like a lot of people
like turn that fucking guy off.
Why is he.
Why is he playing that Goddamn
Harmonica?
I don't want to hear that.
Put it back in your pocket.
You could have your next champion.
You already tainted in these people's
estimation.
Gets attention whore out of their mind.
My life.
Well,
what's worse?
A harmonica or a guy brings a guitar and
start singing folk songs at a party on
the animal house effect,
right?
Yeah.
Beat him over the head with a guitar.
You can shred.
He's going to be fine.
It's great.
If you were looking to hear someone
tread,
that's that.
Okay.
All of these things are like options of
financial apps and you can exercise them
or you cannot exercise.
You don't have to exercise,
but there's an equal number of things
that people would say that are like the
Harmonica.
Like you should be able to do slam
poetry.
Right?
Everyone should be able to do slam
poetry.
If you can't do slam poetry,
I can feed myself.
I can help,
I can.
I can do slam poetry.
I'll show up at a party and everyone
wants to hear slam poetry.
Is that true?
You're just trying to beat me Joe.
You're so adorable.
It's fascinating to me.
That's that harmonicas are this little
tiny thing that people have.
Like there's not other ones.
Right?
There's like other things.
I like these big old trumpet looking
things like a harmonica is this little
thing.
Yeah,
like how many little things do you blow?
Well that's what are that powerful in
terms of like the kind of music did it
makes.
Exactly.
Isn't that weird?
It is weird.
Like there's no like balls,
right?
It's always that.
It's always that little candy bar
looking thing like there's nothing,
no ball harmonica,
comparable in terms of like musical
instruments that does that little nut
that has that kind of sound.
No,
that's what it's optimized for,
but isn't that weird?
Like there's two buzz and there's other
things that are similar and then you get
to like trombones and trumpets.
Everything kind of makes sense.
Then you got this little fucking thing,
so candy bar thing,
right?
A mouth heart,
a mouth harp.
Ooh.
What's that other one?
They bought.
Knowing,
knowing,
knowing these two Jews,
those Jews.
Old timey movies.
Is that what it's called?
Boring.
Now this is like a weird word for it is
a weird word for that thing.
John Harp.
Yeah.
Maybe I'm thinking of a complete.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's one.
That's another weird one where you can
play the spoons.
Spoons are good.
Well,
how about that fucking Australian one
where they blow into the big ones the
most.
That is like how hard were those guys
trip and when they came up with that
sound,
why do I wear like if you're in this
like Tuvan throat singing did that.
He's good.
Thank you.
If you're on Haight Ashbury and there's
a dude and he's got one of them diggory
dues out fucking hat.
You're supposed to throw some money in
there.
Just out of respect.
This guy brought a God damn degree due
to the corner.
Well,
you know the coolest recent one.
It is crazy.
Some noise from this motherfucker.
Just give me a little bit.
That is dmt music.
I know if you're tripping balls and
somebody plays that you,
it'll take you to a new dimension.
So you've never accessed was kind of
like the paint on for it to and
everything.
Oh,
that's not true.
Actually.
It's quite interesting.
The center center diamond church around
the IOWASCA stuff has a lot of really
interesting music to listen to it
straight is the kind of mind mind
blowing.
Well,
there's also,
there's,
I don't know if it's that one or the
something do vegetal.
There's one of those similar Christian
based dimethyltryptamine Iowasca type
churches that they sing songs about
Jesus the trip balls and sing songs
about Jesus and what's really weird
about dmt in particular,
and I guess you could say the same of of
mushrooms,
but mushrooms apparently when it
synthesizes.
Yeah,
it's real similar in chemical content to
what dimethyltryptamine is.
I'm going to fuck this up,
but I think it's an n.
dimethyltryptamine is dimethyltryptamine
and then when it's synthesized by the
body,
when the body processes silicide than I
think it produces something called for
Fox for a lock.
CNN dimethyltryptamine,
I think it's real close.
I might have fucked that up,
but I think it's so close that it's like
their cousins.
Okay,
so there's something about music in
these things and one of the best ways to
get out of a trip if you're,
if you're really tripping balls with
mushrooms,
is the sing your way out of it.
You can sing your way out of a bad trip.
You can actually control the trip with
good music.
And one of the things that's really
constant with Dmt is these arrows that
these shaman will sing and these egos
with symbols and like a little bit of
drum and these like really rhythmic
singing it.
It makes the hallucination dance in like
a really obvious tangible way moves
around itself and it changes in guides
the trip.
Well that's what I.
my hypothesis has been that it's sort of
some sort of.
Yeah,
I guess that's one right there.
This is one of personally experienced.
I've,
I've actually tripped listening to this
song and it was like these geometric
patterns,
these entities that seem to be
conscious,
they were like moving around.
This is the guy,
this is the Iowa scarecrow,
this is the shaman blowing tobacco,
this is part of the ritual.
They actually below tobacco on you,
why you you do that?
So this guy was just this little rattle
and singing and sometimes there's actual
singing,
not just whistling but in their
language,
this beautiful soft,
rhythmic sort of song and the
hallucinations dance to this,
to the sound of this music.
Like they're supposed to dance to it
like they're a part of like it's not
just that you're having music on top of
the psychedelic experience,
but that they merge,
they merge and the psychedelic
experience experience is a hundred
percent affected by this.
So it's not just that there's chemicals
that are interacting with your brain,
your doing something to by responding to
that music and then the music is doing
something by enhancing the way your
perception of this experience is and all
of that is dancing together like they
belong together.
It's fascinating shit.
Yeah.
I mean my hypothesis has been that the
music acts as a prosthesis to sort of
lock you in because the experience is so
powerful.
Yeah.
I mean,
maybe it's always a little bit weird,
you know,
try to imagine somebody says,
do you want a glass of scotch and a
shaman to go with it,
what?
You probably need one,
but you know someone at a bar that's
like,
we're going to drink this,
we're going to drink this good
intentions and no one's going to be
grabbing anybody's Dick.
No one's no one's going and said,
no one's getting rude here.
There would be no wedgies,
right?
There'd be nothing.
Nothing rude will be said.
You will.
You will think for a good solid five
seconds before any hasty moves like
let's,
let's
understand that I let it get great
benefit going to get great benefit from
this in terms of our ability to be loose
and to be silly and to,
to enjoy each other's company.
But if,
if a demon comes out during this time,
you must address this demon personally
on your own.
Don't pull the demon out and throw it at
the party.
Right?
This is good stuff.
That's,
but that's what happened.
So that drunks,
the throne,
that dementia,
that,
that thing where they figured out that
if you put a worm in the mescal stuff,
that would be a great marketing device
north of the border.
Right?
Cause you just tell some stories.
So now we were going to open that.
What that is is just think it's a
marketing gimmick next and then.
And then what we do is we found our own
Tequila company and we only so exclusive
that you can only buy it if you also
hire a charlotte for the event will make
tons of money.
Yeah.
And if.
What if the,
the worm actually was psychedelic.
Like what if there was a way we can
genetically engineer a worm to be
intensely psychedelic.
Like the worm literally is made out of
Iowasca like we.
Why don't we put a toad in the misco?
Well don't they do weird shit like that
with a little take tomatoes and they'll
like use [inaudible] frog DNA in the
tomato to make it live longer.
But isn't.
There was some weird shit.
They're already dealing with.
Cool stuff.
Is the green fluorescent protein stuff
you can have glow in the dark rabbits
and he makes these.
Yes.
Let's get some glow in the dark bunnies,
man.
They can do that right there is
something like that.
Right?
So you have Jamie,
do you have glow in the dark rabbits?
No,
but I do have the genetically modified
potato with frog genes to resist
pathogens while in the holy fuck.
So how weird is that?
GM potato uses frog gene to resist
pathogen.
So that's,
that's real.
Can we do.
Can we do a GFP rabbits?
Yep.
So what were we on before this?
We were talking about how we get to
rabbits.
Tequila with a fraudulent.
So what if we engineer that little worm
to be like a 100 percent dmt,
100 percent dsd where you get down to
that worm and whoever chugs to the
bottom and choose on that warm.
Just call you immediately transformed.
What the fuck am I watching?
These are these glowing rabbits.
Yeah.
That is so weird dude.
It's so weird.
Hoverboards and archery stuff.
We need rabbits.
Who need.
Now here's a problem,
man.
My kids have rabbits in there.
Those rabbits,
a little assholes.
They don't.
They don't give a fuck about each other.
We have two of them is so rude.
This is what happens.
They're both males,
unfortunately.
Here's what happens when you get to mail
bunnies and you put them in a gigantic
chicken coop.
They fuck each other up.
It's bunny UFC everyday with these
little assholes.
All they do is kick each other's ass.
They chase each other around this
chicken coop and when they get a hold of
each other,
they bite each other and they kick each
other.
They fuck each other up because they're
both boys and they don't want a boy to
be running as these two bunnies fucking
each other out.
Dude,
this is what they do.
Bunnies are fucking ruthless to each
other.
These two little assholes just chase
each other all day long and beat the
shit out of each other.
That's all they do.
Why don't you do commentary?
I'm not gonna.
Encourage their batteries.
Ballard,
comment.
One of them is actually missing.
Um,
so here's what happened.
We are chicken coop burnt down from the
fire,
but the chicken survived.
One of them got scorched.
They all got fucking PTSD.
It's crazy.
I go near them,
but they're alive.
Right.
So we had a maneuver them and move them.
But one bunnies missing found one bunny.
One bunnies missing.
So I think it's better for the one bunny
that survived.
And the one bunny that probably got
jacked by an eagle or some shit like
that.
That's a wraps on you had a good life.
He beat the shit out of your friend for
a year and a half solid.
Just kick each other's ass.
It's fucking horrible that his ears are
totally jacked up to hear the shredded.
Like a,
like an old bag to the depth that you
missed?
I don't think so because there's no
body.
I think.
I think a bunny got out and it probably
ran away or who knows what the fuck
happened at Coyote got it.
Or some shit.
I mean there's a lot of hawks,
lot of hawks in my neighborhood.
It's most likely a hawk.
Yeah.
But whatever.
There's one little bunnies by himself
now.
He's like the other asshole.
They're both assholes to each other.
It's not like one good bunny.
They just find each other and like,
fuck you.
I imagined just that's all you do for
years.
That's bunny life.
You get to male buddies together and
everyday is fuck you.
Fuck you.
Fuck yeah.
With they run at each other and one
one's always trying to get away.
One's always trying to eat and the other
one jumped on him and start biting him
and kicking him.
And the other one we'll do the same and
they'll rotate.
You know,
it's very funny.
The uh,
the last two Jews in Afghanistan,
uh,
both had to live in the synagogue.
That was all the head left.
That's really only help somebody.
Somebody went,
somebody went to go visit the last two
Jews in Afghanistan and said like,
why aren't you,
why aren't you guys friends?
And one of them says here,
I'll show you his small want to have
lunch.
The got the guy says,
grow up.
Did you see what I'm working with?
And it's like the most Jewish
conversation between the last two Jews,
they can't get along.
And so they're like the two rabbits that
the,
all the others went away,
whether they're probably really horny
and lonely and confused,
I suppose.
Yeah.
I mean,
what the fuck?
There's only two of them.
They need to get to Israel stat like,
well,
I think one of them died.
And then the last one is just despite
the last guy,
someone talked to him.
If it's possible for you to get to
Jerusalem,
that's your people,
they'll just,
you'll have a party over there.
Everything will be great.
Jewish food,
everyone's speaking Hebrew.
Everyone's united will like the last
three Jews have.
Carola.
Was this young woman and two guys.
Just that.
No,
neither one of you forget this thing.
I know.
It's rough,
man.
It's rough.
It's crazy to think that it's a country
with zero Jews like zero.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Nope.
The whole country like,
Whoa,
whoa.
That is.
That is kind of this melting pot here,
sir.
Zero,
zero melting.
It was one ingredient,
whole pot.
That's all stu.
I'd say it.
It was.
The Taliban actually really needed the
Jewish community because they wanted to
be able to say,
we've had great relations with
Afghanistan Jewish community.
They just didn't say it was two guys,
two dudes that hate each other.
Exactly.
Very polarizing.
True.
I don't know how we got into.
Oh,
glowing bunnies.
I'm not getting any fucking bunnies,
man.
All right.
If you get a guy and a girl together,
you've got to fix the girl.
Otherwise you're going to have a million
bunnies and they're all going to be
kicking each other's asses.
So they do the bunny apocalypse.
Well,
what's really fucked up his reading
about animals that that fight like right
out of the womb,
how they kill their partner.
They killed the good siblicide.
Yeah.
Pull up a obligate siblicide in blue.
Nazca could boobies.
What of those?
What's it in Nazca.
Booby.
They live in the Nazca lines or these.
What are these boobies?
Jamie Hmi out here.
We're hanging out in the word Boobie
Boobie.
I'm still still.
How do you spell that?
Naz,
ca and then boobies.
The usual man.
I'm trying to remember what I was
reading about where obligate siblicide
when one animal comes out,
the other one tries to kill the other
one.
Almost immediately.
Hostile Hyenas,
hyenas,
hyenas.
There's been.
There's been evidence of hyenas
attacking their sibling while it's in
the amniotic sack and theirs.
When they come out,
the bigger one or the stronger one of
the whatever one's healthy will almost
immediately started attacking it.
Sibling and try to kill it.
Pull up that if that's true,
I'm pretty sure that's true,
but I want to see.
Boom.
I went to this crazy rabbit hole about
hyenas recently.
What a bizarre animal that is.
So this the false penis?
Yeah.
The false penis is just one aspect.
Everything.
About 90 percent of the women die.
Okay.
Here it goes.
Obligate symbols,
similar size.
When a sibling almost always ends up
being killed.
Fugitive siblicide means the suicide
facul Tim,
like it's a choice versus you've got to
do a tative.
Faculty tackled facultative syllabus.
Siblicide means a siblicide may or may
not occur based on environmental
conditions.
Okay,
so it's sometimes will happen if there's
not enough resources.
So the idea is that the,
the breeding cycle is retired,
so you either make it or you don't.
And so the danger of laying one egg and
having it not work out is very,
oh,
this bird is fucking.
This is brother up and it has to be in
front of mom and dad because you want to
prove that you're worthy.
Well that is insane,
right?
So Mommy,
look at,
he's beating it to death.
So this is because there's not enough
food,
there's not enough food to do two.
So the first one,
the second one is a spare and the first
one proves,
proves that he's worthy by killing his
sibling.
The spare in front of the parents and
says,
yeah,
you can invest in me.
I got this thing,
Jesus Christ.
And what kind of bird is this is
probably Nazca or blue footed boobies is
my guess.
That is insane.
It's hard to watch.
Well,
this is what I said about biology.
Biology cares about your feelings and
the mom doesn't give a fuck about her.
I don't know the mom the mom wants.
Look,
mom's excited.
This one's dying fucked up,
and the mom's like,
mom's excited.
Hey,
the older one knows what it's doing.
He's viable.
Jesus Christ.
Nature is pretty brutal,
pretty brutal.
Now it's,
it's bizarre seeing this from,
Oh God,
I don't want to see this thing slowly
die,
dude.
It's bizarre seeing it from birds.
But,
uh,
I think it's even more ruthless the way
lions,
hyenas,
hyenas killing their siblings,
that almost a,
I think they were saying it's pretty
universal.
That is when the first one comes out and
they tried to kill a second one with,
you know,
this thing about lion female lions
getting excited by the murder of their
children.
Oh,
so when the new,
when the new mail takes over the pride,
his first order of business may be,
let's stop wasting resources on the
previous daddy's a offspring.
So what happens through this same kind
of thing?
The hyena gets out and immediately
starts killing its sibling.
They're fighting to the death right out
of the womb.
Look at this fucking mad battle as
babies.
Look,
it's still got the sack on it and
they're just trying to kill each other.
This is a particularly ruthless animal.
There were.
There were saying that 60 percent of
hyenas die as a trying to get out of the
tube.
Wow.
What?
I didn't know that.
Yeah,
20 percent of women die.
Whether females rather die when they're
giving birth,
but that's because of our crazy brain to
body ratio.
They have no female hyenas.
Oh,
giant Dick.
Sorry.
I thought you were talking about high
rates of human mentality.
Female Hyena die 20 percent of the time
when they're giving birth because the
baby doesn't come out right.
Like they have this crazy,
you know they have a penis that is
actually a vagina.
It's a.
it's an enormous,
huge and gorge clearest.
It's far bigger than the males.
They have to pull it back so the male
can copulate with them,
but then when they give birth he has to
come out of that Dick and they don't.
It doesn't always come out right,
so system.
Yeah,
Google that because I might be wrong
about the numbers,
but it's some exorbitant number of
babies die and a huge number of women.
Women.
I keep saying women,
female,
Hyena is done.
Yeah.
That's why I fuck up,
but there are also weird and that
they're way bigger than the males and
that's the because the males won't let
the babies eat,
so this one of the things they think
like if somethings are scavengers,
the males are trying to push out
everything smaller.
So because of that the females have to
get in and go fuck off.
The kid has to eat like even if it's
their kid that's cool.
Sixty percent suffocate on their way
out.
Sixty percent of them die on the way
Yeah,
and I think it's 20 percent of the
females die during childbirth as well.
Pretty sure.
That's what I read,
which is fucking.
I mean,
60 percent though.
Imagine 60 percent of all kids die on
the way out and then the ones that don't
die,
if you got two of them,
one of them kills the other one.
It's a rough neighborhood.
Oh,
it's a matriarchal society and they give
birth through that fake penis.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
What is the purpose of the fake penis?
What does take peanuts is a dominate the
men.
They get on top of the band and they go,
listen,
bitch,
so it's going to be.
And they got a big old strap on.
They pegged their men at all.
Male hyenas are cooks.
They all take.
It's crazy.
That's where we're heading as a
condition.
Diameter.
Really?
Jesus.
Ouch.
Tight squeeze that.
That creates a high death rate for first
time mothers.
Yeah.
High death rate is and say here,
how many.
But I think it's 20 percent.
You've ever seen the,
the,
uh,
like the full human cliteracy?
Yes.
I've seen one.
Have you?
Uh,
not in the wild.
The full,
the full clitoral.
No,
I know.
I've never seen it.
Like a biological.
Can you pull up the internal clutters
internal clinic?
I think it was only discovered.
Is it not allowed to be shown to
quickly?
Think about that.
Yeah.
It'll cause trouble.
Well,
you could pull it up and just don't show
the world.
Just show us if you.
I think if you put that on Youtube,
we will be monetized and possibly kicked
off their network to Google that
yourself.
Yeah,
Google it.
You weirdo and be careful of the wrath
of the government.
Enormous structure that I think we
didn't fully understand.
I don't understand how we could have
missed it,
but my understanding was we didn't fully
understand the internal cliteracy there
on the left below.
It looks exactly like this sort of space
ships from war of the worlds 1953.
It's all that stuff on the outside.
All you see on the outside,
that little tip at the top,
we're going to get in trouble.
They get mad at us.
Does that picture make you horny?
No,
not at all.
Afraid,
doesn't it?
It seems like an alien.
I should shoot laser blogger like that's
the Ridley Scott Alien.
The face hugger.
Yeah.
Well,
just the look.
It's very weird that we've just come to
accept what the shape of the body.
His body is very bizarre.
I mean if we were all shaped like sting
rays and we saw a person,
we'd be like,
what in the holy fuck is that thing
with?
It's articulating fingers and it's
moving.
It's eyeballs,
rounds,
sniffing things,
but its nostrils.
Like we just accept the fact that this
shape is,
is normal,
that it makes sense.
Well,
this is why cephalopods from last time
when we were talking about the
cuttlefish.
Yeah.
My,
I just learned something new,
which is the cephalopods are under
consideration to be the next great model
organism for biology.
So if you think about how weird it is
that some branch of the phylogenetic
tree is so far distant from us that
these mollusks have such advanced minds
and you know,
their skin is the wonder of the world
for sure.
Um,
nobody knows quite how all of that.
Not only do they have these chromatic to
get the camouflage right,
but they also changed the texture of
their skin to mimic things like coral
and all this stuff.
Oh,
wouldn't it be cool if we made
cephalopods the next great model
organism and then we started doing
comparative,
like not only neuroanatomy but
connectomics where we're trying to study
how their brains are organized because
they're so far away.
They're probably the closest we will
ever get to meeting aliens.
I think I said that the last time was
here and I'm really excited if that goes
forward.
Well,
it really doesn't seem like anything
else.
Right.
You know,
whether it's a cuttlefish or whether
it's an octopus like it,
you're like,
oh,
it's Kinda like a squid.
Like,
yeah,
a little bit like a person's like a
monkey.
Yeah.
But like real different than Nautilus is
the craziest.
Maybe the cuddle fish is the most
interesting for sure.
But they're both intelligent.
Right.
But like you regenerate.
That's another part of it.
That's bizarre.
Yeah.
Well it'd be fun to do.
I mean,
I would imagine that Knutson Salamanders
in the tetrapod category would be the
best for us to study for regeneration.
I like how they regenerate up to a point
like nature say.
Yeah,
you can grow an arm back.
Kinko head back.
Sorry.
Fuck face.
That's a wrap.
Yeah.
You know,
you lose your head nature.
Like,
ah,
you gave up a big piece.
He gave up the queen over.
Yeah.
Game's over.
So you thought if you lose your tail,
like that's debatable.
Do you grow your tail back?
We could do that,
right?
Lizards grow their tail back,
but they only grow like most of it.
They don't grow the whole thing,
but the knutson salamanders seemed to
have very high regena and you can just
get in an arm off over and over again.
There is.
We can't cut their head off.
Yeah.
Why do you wanna cut their head off?
Well,
I don't,
but I mean just saying it's weird,
like you can't like chop them in half
from the waist down.
They don't seal up and grow a new waste.
Like that's it.
You can only get rid of the limbs.
Yeah,
but you can get rid of the limps.
Like nature is evolved a strategy for
dealing with probation.
Just give them the arm given the ticket
pop.
What do you make of the fact that we had
this,
a successful head transplant in monkeys
in the early seventies and then we
walked away from it.
Probably good move.
Otherwise chicks at Beverly Hills,
it'd be getting new bodies just getting
their head screwed on to new release.
Yeah,
get new heads.
Yeah.
People would figure out a way to
transplant the brains.
Everyone wants to live forever,
man.
I just have an 800 year old brain and
talk about how your old motorcycle
victim.
Yeah,
so people are going to start doing well
then.
I guess it's thing that we walked.
I thought it was kind of a a weird move
that will succeed at that and then say,
okay,
too much can't handle it.
Do you think that's what they did?
Oh,
it was probably hard to get funding.
People thought you were playing.
God,
the guy who did it,
I think it was maybe his name is Robert
White and he was a devout Christian,
so it was really.
It was good because you know,
there was a lot of this reverence for
the human form and if a religious person
is doing it,
we feel better than if somebody is like
desecrating.
Right,
right.
Some atheist as scientists,
but he's cutting heads off dogs and
Maria attaching them to monkeys.
Yeah.
That's what's also like.
We think of it as like,
okay,
it's one thing if you're trying out
medicine on a monkey that might save
babies,
but it's another thing if you just say,
hey,
what happens if I cut this monkey's head
off,
stick it on another monkey where there's
all this crazy.
I don't know if you've ever seen this.
The Russians had this film introduced by
Jbs Haldane,
great English biologist who was also a
communist and therefore very pro Soviet,
and there's this experiment,
uh,
was experiments in a continuation of the
brain after death and they hook up the
head to an artificial circulatory system
and they sort of continued to have
interactions where they swab the head
and they get the eyelash movement in the
tongue comes out and eat things.
It's quite interesting.
I would recommend it.
Yeah.
How Dean has one of the greatest quotes,
not only as the universe queer,
then you suppose it's queer.
Then we can suppose what a great quote.
He was also the inordinate fondness,
a Beatles guy,
inordinate fondness needles.
The Archbishop of Canterbury found
himself,
I think,
seated across from how Dane and wanted
to needle him because he was a communist
atheist and he said,
you know,
tell me what,
what,
what does your study of the biological
would inform us about how great creator
and how they shot him back.
He said that he has an inordinate
fondness for beetles because beetles are
so highly speciated.
And what was his reaction to that?
Well,
I think it was a different era,
like smoked burn,
but like to our,
to our way of thinking.
It's not that hard of a burn.
Well,
we're really committed to the idea that
all the stuff that we can do
manipulating the planet,
sending rockets into space,
that that's more important than what an
ant does.
What we're really committed to this,
that our significance,
although it's clearly if we're working
together,
we believe in a sense of community.
It's more important to eat each other.
To us it is,
but to the whole thing is it really more
important?
Says you mean if people didn't exist,
we were wiped off the planet by all the
other animals.
Would it be okay?
Really?
Would be okay.
I mean,
we would gain and lose more predators
and we wouldn't be controlling the
population.
Sure.
But if all the aunts went away,
that would be a wrap.
Yeah,
that'd be a wrap.
We're done.
No more people.
This hasn't been widely decided that if
we lost all insect book,
especially all ants like it probably
would collapse all the ecosystems that
we need to sustain human life.
I have a feeling that those waterbury
tardigrades would be like,
suck.
I got rid of the ads were the only ones
left.
Well,
we wouldn't be able to make it,
but a lot of shit would make it a lot of
other stuff.
That's true,
but the thing that I think maybe we'd
make it anyway.
Maybe they're wrong.
Just don't understand human trying to
freak us out.
Yeah.
Maybe didn't read the Fi.
Find out if that's true.
If all aunts died,
human beings would go extinct.
Just Google that I think.
I think I read a paper proposing that
and they were explaining the critical
role that ants play in all these
different ecosystems and how the bio
mass of ants worldwide is equal to or
greater than the biomass of human
beings.
Okay.
I don't have any intuition around that.
Yeah,
sounds reasonable though.
I'm pretty sure that's true.
And so,
but our ideas that were more important.
Well,
we are.
I have cable.
Yeah.
That's why I think we're more four g,
four G.
okay.
That maybe that's more important.
I have a 70 inch television and,
and I,
I have an Iwatch.
Yeah.
It must be more important than stupid.
Fucking ant was dirt house.
If I can just piss on your house while I
go jogging.
Yeah.
I'm a more.
A more important thing than you.
Yeah.
I don't know.
My intuition half your people by pissing
on you.
Yeah.
Obviously nature is want to protect you.
You got your house in the dirt.
It's a whole mound.
Okay.
I don't know why I want to get serious
on.
You're just trying to fuck with me.
The really interesting thing about
humans is that we're the only species
that understands what game we're in and
we can reject the game.
Every other species is playing the game.
So,
you know,
you,
my brother very well,
very surprising to me that my brother
only wanted to have two kids and didn't
want to spend all his time down at the
sperm bank.
Uh,
you know,
making donations.
I said,
you're an evolutionary theorist.
You ever think it's kind of weird that
you're not playing this game very
effectively?
And he shot me back this thing he said,
if you actually understand the game,
why would you want to continue to play
it?
I thought that was really interesting
that somebody who sounds like his wife
does want anymore kids rationalizations.
I get it,
bro.
Yeah.
The article I found says all all insects
dying,
not just answer,
Oh,
insects.
And we take 50 years for people to
disappear for that.
According to this,
a science explorer article,
um,
find out the biomass of ants because
that's even trippier
open.
I'm,
but I want to get rid of this anti human
thing because I'm not answering.
I know.
No,
you're assuming neutral.
Knowing biologically neutral.
If I just looked at it objectively.
Yeah,
I know.
I said you don't think so.
You think it's more significant because
we're more significant to each other?
Well,
there's no significance in the whole
game if you just take completely
materials.
Like what do we care is one rock,
one SPEC,
big deal.
Right?
So the problem is if you accept that as
an answer,
then you've kind of failed by just
taking the nihilist way out and to me
like they have this annual question,
that edge.org,
and then finally the guy got exhausted
and want to ask another one.
So I'll finish this up quick and then
we'll you think I'm
sorry.
No,
you want to take it and do our aunts
outweigh humans?
Individual workers way an average
between one to five milligrams according
to the species.
When combined all ants in the world
taken together way about as much as all
human beings.
That's interesting.
Wow.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
That's fucking bananas.
Who they are,
15 to 20 percent of the terrestrial
animal biomass and in tropical regions
where answer especially abundant,
they monopolize 25 percent or more.
I'm an after I have a buddy of mine,
Brian Cowen,
Ryan accountant used to,
uh,
he,
when he was in college,
he spent some time in the jungle.
He was thinking he was going to be a
biologist and he was going to study
insect who's going to be in,
what is it in insectivore.
And so they had to sleep in these
elevated tents and they had to paint
like some sort of like Turpentine type
chemical all over the posts because of
they didn't.
The ants would crawl up the post and eat
you and your sleep would literally climb
in your ear and start eating you and
tell everybody and you would die that
way.
Like people have died and elephants have
been eaten by ants and he said,
you can hear them walking in the jungle
like in the night you hear,
you hear the footsteps of fucking ants
because there's so many of us.
If you're in the wrong place at the
wrong time.
And there's a path of these
motherfuckers moving your way and they
send a signal that we got something here
and they crawl up you,
they just all start crawling up you.
And there's so many of them,
you can't avoid them
because they're not really separate
animals right there.
Use Social Hymenoptera has this weird
property of this haplodiploid structures
so that the females are highly related
to each other.
And so in the same way that your cells
aren't individual animals,
they all conspire to create you.
There is a sense in which in this world
of bees and ants and wasps and things.
Hi,
my Hymenoptera,
the real entity is the colony.
It's not the individual,
right?
So,
you know,
if I took a cytological approach,
um,
to you and I just went set cell by cell,
you know,
you're,
you're this collection of,
uh,
you know,
10 or 50 trillion separate entities.
And that's what makes ants so terrifying
is that,
you know,
Kropotkin and the great anarchistic a
sort of an amateur naturalist.
And he,
he would look to natural systems and
say,
why can't humans cooperate like this?
The point is,
we're not structured to cooperate in
this use social fashion.
The way they cooperate is so uncanny.
When those leaf cutter ants designed
those intricate cities with,
they have places where things for meant
and were gases are released through
holes in the ground and it doesn't make
any
sense that this little tiny brain could
figure out this enormous structure,
but somehow or another when combined,
and not just any brain,
right,
not just one,
one version of this,
but millions and millions of these
designs appear all over the world and
they see if he could find that video.
Have they filled a leaf cutter ant
colony?
They filled the home with molten metal.
Yeah.
It was something like that.
I think they.
They flooded it with concrete.
They flooded concrete in all the holes
and then they dug out everything around
it so you could see this structure and
then they explained what.
This is really well thought out,
like they have portals and they have
the.
This is how they get the food in and
this is where they take the leaves and
they,
they let them rot and turn into mulch
and there's like a gas remedies
distributed loosely coupled system
would.
It makes it seem so amazing.
It is utterly amazing.
But if you think about it as individuals
making decisions that conspire to create
these,
these structures,
it's less,
it's,
that's more amazing than what it is,
which is,
it's a loosely coupled,
a distributed system,
you know,
so that's how a bee hive will send out
explorers and they'll report back and
they'll do the dance and the dance
communicates the information and you get
all these coordinated activities.
Um,
in what other systems do you suppress
the fertility of females because the
relatedness is so high.
This is gorgeous.
Yeah.
This is the video we're talking about.
So this is really huge too.
And they have these looks like tunnel
systems and then they lead to these big
circular areas where they're really
almost uniform in size and it's a really
strange way or similar in size.
They.
So they have these pathways that go to
these like rooms,
you circular rooms and there's just this
incredible network of these tubes and
circular rooms that they uncover and
it's fucking enormous when you look at
how big this thing.
I mean if you had to like how big is
that?
Was that 80 feet across,
90 feet across or something like that.
Good,
good.
So they're continuing to dig this up.
They're not even done in this video
here,
but you see all the pipes that extend to
the left and to the right.
So they've developed some sort of
complex civilization,
some weird bizarre network of these
passageways and rooms and they do it
just like this everywhere.
So some pattern has emerged in their
species that has set them up to act as
this collective group and then operate
in a similar fashion all over the world.
Wherever they exist in that sort of with
that kind of dirt they can manipulate,
right?
That that's dad alone is one that is a
massive mystery.
Hey,
how a little tiny thing with a brain
that's almost imperceptibly small.
This is like tiny little head,
his little head was he figured out that
whole,
how do you figuring out tunnels that
he's not really not.
This is what I'm trying to get out there
working together.
Okay.
So if you look at,
for example,
Si elegans,
the nematode with a thousand cells for
the entire body plan,
300 of which are neurons.
We have a complete map,
not only of the cell lineage diagram,
which is how this thing unfolds from a
single fertilized egg,
but we also have a complete wiring
diagram of its nervous system.
So this is something that locomotive
moves around and eats,
has sex and it's only got 300 neurons.
Each of those is extremely primitive
machine and they send signals to each
other and we still don't know that how
the thing really works.
Even though we've got the entire thing
mapped.
Jesus,
this was the great insight of Sydney
Brenner that we would make the,
the worm,
uh,
the great model organism because we
could actually map everything about it.
Right?
And it is astounding to me how little
we've learned.
We've learned a ton from it,
but I had thought that we would have
gotten much farther and understanding
the brain.
Did you see this recent discovery of a
25 foot long sea worm that apparently is
not just one organism has many organisms
together combined?
No.
Yeah.
I've got to find out about that.
You got to see this fucking thing.
It's insane and I think there's a very
recent discovery,
at least one this large and these guys
are swimming around with this thing.
It looks impossible.
It looks like they landed on another
planet and they're experiencing this
thing like this thing,
this whatever this is.
I'm pretty sure that what I read,
I read it really quickly as I was
running out the door that it exists.
Large eight mil eight meter worm,
like sea creature stuns New Zealand
divers,
so they're looking at this thing,
but I think there's many different
organisms inside of it and I don't think
it's one individual organism.
Yeah.
It's made up of hundreds of thousands of
organisms.
I've never seen that.
Yeah.
Like what?
What is it like?
What does that mean?
Is this is a weird tube for folks that
are watching this or listening to this
rather,
what we're looking at is these divers
that are just tripping balls here,
they're like,
what in the fuck is this?
And it looks like like an enormous tube,
like Jelly fish type creature that's in
the water.
It almost looks semi translucent,
right?
Would you say?
And this tour Finland,
it's enormous.
It's so.
It's like the size and what moves and
changes,
but at sometimes it's larger than a
human waste or a human chest and other
times it gets real skinny,
but it's a fucking huge.
Like look at that.
What is that thing that.
I'm stunned by the fact that it's like I
don't understand what they're saying,
that it's made up of hundreds of
thousands of organisms.
Like how is it made up of different
stuff?
Like what is it like?
Have you ever heard of anything like
this?
I like the Portuguese man of war I think
is like five different organisms,
isn't it?
Isn't it?
The collaborate in effect really the
Portuguese man of war is not like a one
thing.
Look at the size of that thing above the
water.
That is fucking crazy.
Piracy home.
Just whatever the ocean is like that.
Like we're all.
We're trying to look into space.
Like I wonder if there's aliens out
there.
There's no.
Whether it's cuddle fish or octopus or
this goddamn thing.
Whoa.
Pyro Psalm.
What the fuck?
That thing looks like.
A geometric pattern.
That's a nice one.
Look at that.
One of the upper right hand corner.
Jamie,
what does that weird looking fucking.
What is that thing?
60 foot long jet powered animal.
Oh God.
It's like a civilization.
It's like a ship of these things flying
through the ocean.
What?
Have you ever seen this before?
What the fuck is that?
That is so weird looking.
Uh,
come on man.
That looks like something from Avatar
doesn't.
Yeah,
it totally does.
Right?
Like something that comes up that tree
hopefully put it in the new movie.
Yeah.
Tell Call James Cameron.
Look at this thing.
So this is what those things are,
but the other one is a very smooth or
it's low resolution and we can't get a
really good look at it.
But that's what it is,
is this collective group of hundreds of
thousands of organisms that combined
together and they're getting jacked by
that turtle.
All you bitches.
What a weird,
weird organisms that look at this
picture if you stuck your arm in it and
it just.
Dude,
how bizarre is it?
The disease of civilization of these
things all combined.
But what they are is individuals that
operate as a giant tube.
You never heard of this before.
Now I'm so happy we found something.
You don't know about your stuff,
man.
That was fucking weird one man.
But the.
Yeah,
the idea that the ocean is really an
alien world.
Yeah.
Well the funniest part is when you hear
these guys with their remote
submersibles and they find some new life
for them.
Yeah.
They're like,
take me down.
Believe me.
Those.
Wait.
What does that feel like?
They get really excited because it's,
it's the ability to meet aliens.
There are new things.
Yeah.
I mean we,
we've Kinda sorta mapped out the stuff
more or less or.
Yeah,
there's like a few weird things you find
in the jungle.
Weird bugs.
Like where's that?
Vietnam has some surprises for us here
with fangs.
Ever seen those?
Oh,
the Sulawesi boars or they'll the deer
really damn empire,
dear.
I Dunno.
I Dunno about vampires here.
It's the craziest looking thing ever.
It's deer with fangs like crocodile look
and fangs that come hanging down like
this.
If this is some jackalope thing.
No,
it's not.
It's a weird little animal.
It's not a big deer either.
Well,
do you know?
Look at that thing vampire,
dear.
That's a real animal.
Look at that.
How fucking strange.
What was it?
What was in this coffee?
Jamie?
Look at that thing will get their
fucking teeth on that thing.
It's probably something akin to their
antlers.
They use it to defend themselves.
Okay.
That's not real.
Not Real,
because that's a mule deer,
so that one that you just pick some
photoshop bullshit.
What's interesting is apparently I'm elk
have these things called the people call
them Ivoree's now,
but they.
What they are is at one point in time
they had tusks like a boar,
like giant toss.
It probably aided them in their fights
and they eventually shrank and now
they're just this weird sort of nubby
thing.
I'm actually have some here.
I'll show it to you.
Yeah.
The after the podcast will show them to
you,
but they,
they're this weird thing that's not
quite a tooth.
It's ivory.
It grows inside their head.
And at one point in time it was some
kind of a weapon,
just like their head is.
I mean the antlers,
you know,
it's the largest.
How do we describe this?
What was the,
the,
the quickest growing thing in the animal
world is the,
the antlers of an elk because look how
fucking huge they are.
They fall off every year and they grow
back every year and it's all just for
fighting.
And they used to grow back tusks to
where they used to have.
The acid tests were permanent,
but they used to just.
That's just for Duking it out.
It's crazy weaponry,
sexual selection.
Well,
you went into a really weird thing and
the Dung Beetle,
um,
there's a conserved system whereby in
some dung beetles,
the amount of weaponry you have as your
antler is inversely proportional to the
amount of military apparatus you have,
where it counts.
And so if you have really impressive
weaponry,
you're not able to do quite as much,
and that may be the engine of
speciations because the vagina and
penis,
that system is a lock and key.
And so if something shrinks too much,
then you can't necessarily get,
get the Job Sofa,
greedy.
Dung beetle with giant horns just fucks
everybody up.
His genes can pass on.
Maybe there's a certain amount of
cooperation is needed in the dung world.
Can have an oppressor,
can have a gang,
is con of the Dung Beetle world,
the Patriarchy and the Dung beetle
world.
Look at the size of the antler on that
guy,
but girls make fun of them.
Probably the dung beetle world because
like the guy with the Lamborghini,
exactly like what's he doing over there
with these giant?
It looks like elk antlers probably is a
tiny little dick.
You want.
You want to,
God's just got little like that,
like that guy probably probably hung
like a roach.
Right?
Have a hunting question for you.
Okay.
I started looking into this primitive
hunting thing.
I was positively predisposed towards
hunting and I turned myself off of.
I mean I don't hunt,
but I turned myself off of hunting by
watching the effect of some of these
people who are baiting and killing bears
in ways that it just doesn't feel to me
like hyper respectful and I wondered if
there's like a deeper layer where if I
got even deeper into it,
I would understand it or am I actually
correct that there is something weird
about the effect of attracting some
beautiful bear to a kind of easy place
to kill it and then just getting super
excited about doing it in well,
how
your natural instincts,
there's a reason for them and you're
most certainly correct.
It's,
it's a weird feeling.
The idea that you're going to trick this
bear and thinking he's going there to
eat and then you kill them.
Bear hunting is different than any other
kind of haunting in the.
First of all,
there's a lot of emotional attachment to
it because people love teddy bears and
things along those lines,
but bears are this idea that they're
beautiful.
They've definitely are.
They definitely are.
They're also one of the more ruthless
animals in the animal kingdom and
they're all cannibals.
All of them and the males don't.
Don't just go after the cubs.
They eat them and they go after them
specifically to eat them,
and then when the males get chased off
the female,
what year on cubs,
and this is universal,
there are also responsible for the death
of at least 50 percent of undulate
calves and Fonz,
whether it's moose,
cows,
somebody.
I don't have any of these issues.
So they also are really difficult to
hunt and their populations thought by
wildlife.
Biologists are important to keep under
control by all of that.
So in areas of extreme density like
forest,
you will not kill them unless you bait.
You will not.
So if you one of two things has to
happen.
Either they have to use dogs,
which is what they used to use a lot.
These used to be California until the 19
nineties.
They outlawed hound hunting and then the
odd baiting around the same time.
What they essentially did,
northern cal in California is they
outlawed bear hunting,
but they didn't.
You can still hunt bears,
but it's extremely difficult,
almost impossible with a bow or very,
very unlikely,
like your rate of success of extremely
low if you want to control populations,
if you like to eat moose and deer or you
want to have them keep healthy
populations and you don't want the bare
encroaching on these rural homes and
these areas,
you have to control their populations
and there's very few other ways to
control them.
Relations other than baiting them,
so assume that I was positively
predisposed to hunting.
I do think that they're beautiful
creatures.
I think they're emotional creatures,
but I understand they're all.
They're all beautiful.
I think.
I mean,
I think the frogs are beautiful.
They're fascinating.
It's the effect that freaked me out.
It should.
It's a weird form of trickery and we
don't think it's sporting right,
but the idea is that if you really want
to control their populations,
you have to accept that this is a
necessary evil so that I grasped that
it's still at the level that the thing
that surprised me was that the effect
wasn't the expected effect of the hunter
with reverence in some sense.
Sufficient reverence for the kill.
Yeah,
that's what flipped me out.
Well,
there's people get excited and they get
happy that they're successful because
hunting is difficult and then if you
take that into context,
if you take that out of context and
people get happy,
especially when they're happy,
they're getting happy around people that
have no problem with hunting scene,
one of the problems with respect is that
it's assumed that you only have that
respect if you don't have happiness.
That goes along with that.
I understand that there is some amount
of sadness,
some amount of happiness is a weird
feeling of loss,
so there's a lot of weird stuff that
goes on.
Surprised,
and the reason I'm asking you is,
is that I had expected that I would have
the difficulty bears equals teddy bears.
I get past that.
I keep going around this whole thing.
Then when I finally got to the end,
it was just the.
There wasn't the right balance between
sadness,
ecstatic elation.
It's hard.
It's hard to.
It's hard if you're not there
experiencing it.
It's hard if you're not involved in this
hunt for many,
many days and it gets very difficult
when and you don't know if it's ever
going to happen,
but the bear hunting in particular,
especially over Bait,
is way more problematic psychologically.
No,
I think there's a really good argument
and I support this argument that you
must keep bear populations in control if
you want people and and all those other
animals to live in harmony.
Got It.
Because if you don't,
there's nothing else that keeps your
populations in control by that other
than bigger bears.
Grizzly bears and grizzly bears and they
get out of hand our way scarier.
That's a real.
It's a real science,
real giant problem in terms of our,
our anthropomorphization of these
animals,
you know,
attaching these human attributes and
these human thoughts and thinking of
them as our friends in the forest and
then what they actually are the people
that live out there.
No.
My guess is that if I went hunting with
you,
I would expect to see elated after
three days of frustration on a,
on a good hunt.
I expect that you would use the kill
responsibly,
that you would forgo certain kinds of
Kilz.
I don't have any of those issues.
I think.
I think that where the issue is is that
I wouldn't expect an unbalanced elation.
Yeah,
I understand what you're saying and
especially an unbalanced elation when
you're hunting over bait,
right?
For an animal that is not necessarily
thought of in our culture as being an
animal that you eat,
which is bear and a lot of times people
think that you don't eat them.
Black bears in particular actually,
they taste very good and people do eat
them.
When you deal with people,
like I have friends,
my friend John and Jen Rivet who live in
Alberta and there they are hunting
guides.
It's a real necessity up there to hunt
bears.
Okay.
Because there is nothing else.
It's keeping their populations in check
and if you ever go up there,
you see an extraordinary amount of
bears.
Like you could see 19,
20 bears in a day.
Well they're everywhere and there's a
high density of them and they just
decimate the deer population.
They decimate the Moose population and
there's some of them that learn that
they can get into garbage cans,
they can break into people's cars and
destroy them.
They've killed a few people,
but it's pretty rare.
Most of the time they realized that
people are dangerous and they stay the
fuck away,
but it's not what I.
What I appreciate his spot and stocking
traditional prey animals.
That's what I like to do.
I like to spot and stalk deer and elk
because I feel like first of all,
they're the most delicious they make.
Whether it makes sense or not,
they make the most sense to me in terms
of like a prey animal.
They're the ones that I covet the most.
What I want to do is I want to go and
get older,
mature animals that are undulates.
Whether it's a deer or an elk or the
animal that has spread its genetics that
has already,
it's,
you know,
seven,
eight years old,
nine years old as animal that doesn't
have much time left.
If you get it now,
you're probably getting it within a year
of its death.
Whether it's by natural causes,
wolves,
cold,
starvation,
you're.
You're doing it probably the most humane
you're giving it probably the most
humane death.
It's reasonably possible for this thing
is unless it falls off a cliff,
and even then it's the.
It might survive that for a little
while.
When you're shooting an animal with an
Arrow,
it's dead in seconds.
You know,
you hit it in the heart and they shot an
elk this year.
It literally walked four yards and
tipped over it.
Just step,
step,
boom.
I'm very impressed with the skill of
some of these.
I guess this is the print primitive
hunting movement with spears and see
that's.
I think you should.
I think it should be really careful
about anything that you do.
That's not that accurate.
That's.
That's
an issue.
Yeah.
That's a giant issue.
Aba bowser extremely accurate,
right?
I mean there's guys that can shoot a
paper plate at 100,
20 yards every single time.
They could shoot a a good,
a little plate like that.
They'll.
They'll bet their life that could drop
an Arrow into that at 120 yards every
single time.
You can get good at that.
You can get if you have good technique
and reasonable control of your emotions
and your anxiety in the heart,
in the heat of the moment.
You don't ever shoot anything in 120
yards though.
You shooting at things 30 yards,
40 yards and the degree of success is
very high with skilled hunters.
If you are ethical and the shy,
they're shot decisions.
That primitive stuff.
It's like,
why?
Why you throwing spears like,
what are you doing?
You're trying to prove that you're
better than people that use a bow and
Arrow,
like this is not an accurate or
effective thing.
I mean it kind of is,
but you have to be like five yards,
10 yards.
What do you got to be 15 yards Max.
Even then,
I think part of the thrill of it for
them is putting themselves in danger.
There's a little bit of that.
If you're shooting,
oh,
you're going after a bear.
Yeah.
Like I've seen some of these things
filmed where the person looks like
they're up in there.
I don't know what to call it,
their little treestand Tristan,
and that doesn't look like they're
putting a lot of risks,
but some of these people are clearly
getting off on this is the primal hunt.
Right,
and this is.
They're going backwards into something
where the animal could surprise them.
And what I.
What I wanted to do is I wanted to
reacquaint myself with,
you know,
now that I can,
I can watch somebody.
Actually,
in that moment,
I'm trying to figure out what my ethics
around hunting were and I thought that I
had prepared myself and I just,
I thought when I,
when I saw you,
um,
find out where joe is because I have no
question.
Knowing your ethics and how you think
that you would have a very subtle
perspective on all these different kinds
of kills.
Which sorts of animals.
Yeah.
If you get to spears,
you're in a weird place.
Like,
like you say,
oh,
I only spear wild pigs.
We're trying to get rid of many way.
Okay,
well that's.
We're in a weird place where in a weird
place because ethically I think you have
two choices.
Three choices.
Your three choices are rifle,
which is number one,
ethically realistically,
because if you shoot something with a
rifle,
you,
you can be really accurate,
uh,
like out to 100 yards a hundred percent
of the time.
Like unless it's crazy windy out or
there's some weird conditions,
altitude can affect ballistics but not
that much out to 100 yards.
You're fucking deadly.
If you have a really good control,
squeezing,
squeezing the trigger,
you're not jerking everything and not
panicking,
then Beau is second,
you know,
blow.
It requires way more practice way,
way more,
a fine tuning of your motor skills,
but it's still possible.
Okay.
Then you have crossbow,
which is even more effective than a bow,
faster,
more feet per second,
faster feet per second so that it
travels at a flat line because it's
going quicker before it drops.
They all drop at the same speed,
right?
Bullets and arrows all drop at the same
speed.
They just don't get there at the same
speed,
so the same amount of time,
like if I'm shooting something at a
hundred yards with a bow I am aiming
with,
with a site that is calculating for the
fact that the Arrow is going to drop
significantly in the time that it takes.
If it's going 280 feet per second is
like a normal speed for a good bow.
The good heavy Arrow that's 280 feet per
second that goes a hundred yards.
A bullet is going to go 100 yards far
quicker,
but in the same amount of time it takes
that Arrow to get to that target.
The bullet is going to drop the same
amount as the Arrow and that's what most
people don't understand,
so across crossbow is more ethical
because it's more accurate.
It's have fewer moving parts.
You could actually sit it on a rest and
just squeeze the trigger easier to
manipulate and the the Arrow is
traveling faster so it's called a bolt
traveling faster so it'll drop less
after that chick gets squirrely after
that.
It's like you're throwing spears.
Okay.
You got what do you got?
An adult adol.
Okay.
All right.
Well you can kill things with it and
people have done it,
but it gets to.
How accurate are you and it.
What is.
What's your ethical brain like?
An ethical range for a really good
hunter with a bow and arrow is probably
80 yards.
I.
It may be.
Maybe it's a moose,
90 yards,
something big,
but with a spear like what do you got?
You got 10 yards so you know why?
That's the question.
Are you doing it for meat?
Are you doing it because,
um,
is this your Mount Everest?
You want to kill a pig with a spear?
And Are you saying that a pig is not
worth as much?
So you should be able to kill it with a
spear because these are all weird,
weird decision.
Just that weird decisions and people
make those with bears.
They make those decisions with black
bears,
like people that live where they
consider them nuisances.
Th,
they,
they killed them.
I mean they used to be used to allow
them to shoot a,
you still allowed to hunt,
used to be allowed to hunt black bears
with a spear in Alberta until uh,
a big scandal a couple of years ago
where a guy filmed himself doing that.
He shot a bear.
He killed a bear rather with a spear and
was hooting and hollering and people got
a hold of the video and thought it was
disgusting and protested it.
And then,
uh,
people,
from underarmour dropped his,
uh,
wife from there,
you know,
they had this sort of sponsorship deal
with them and uh,
it,
it ignited,
it caused a rift in the hunting
community.
Some people think you should be able to
hunt with a rock here,
what you hunt with Sheila Hunt with
anything and other people like,
hmm,
okay,
but what are we doing?
Are we just going out to get meat or are
we putting on a macho performance of
our.
But this is exactly what I wanted to get
at,
which is if you know that the population
has to be controlled and you want the
meat,
yeah,
then it makes sense to me that you have
to open yourself up to some of the
pleasure of the kill.
That makes some sense.
But what I saw just like flipped me out
because if it wasn't a,
it was,
it was above and beyond.
Yeah.
I saw spirit and other things and you
know,
I was impressed by the,
some of the skill.
I'm impressed by some of the bravery,
but like why doing it to population
control,
you're doing it for the middle.
This was a surprise to me is that I got,
I got kind of sickened by it.
That's not surprising.
It's not surprising,
you know,
I mean,
I think if you,
if you were there,
you'd probably be even more conflicted
because you actually were there in the
presence of the thing.
Dying,
watching bare die on video is one thing.
But being there alive when they die as a
completely different thing,
um,
it's,
it's a very complicated thing because we
have these deep set
emotional connections to certain animals
that my friend Steve Rinella,
who's going to be actually on tomorrow,
he calls them charismatic megafauna that
we have this different view of certain
animals bears in particular.
But if you use the animal respectfully,
respectfully,
and you kill it ethically and you do.
I don't have any problem with hunting
bears.
In fact,
I think it's actually,
it really is a necessary task.
It it's something that even if you don't
like to hunt bears,
if you're living in a place like
Alberta,
you probably should hunt bears because
you should do your part.
There's a lot of them out there and you
know,
one of the things that becomes an
interesting relationship is a
relationship between the moose hunters
and the deer hunters and the bear
hunters that they have.
Kind of those smart ones have come to an
understanding that even if I don't hunt
bear,
I need those people out there doing it,
but it's how do you do it and why you
doing it.
I think I've seen animals die very
quickly with the bone marrow.
They die very quickly.
I've never seen an animal die with a
spear.
Don't think it's necessary,
but I don't want to be the person that
tells you you can't do it.
If you have an ethical range of five
yards and you only hunt,
bear with a spear at five yards and you
kill it immediately,
you hit it and kill it.
You're right.
Then you're right based on the method.
It's based on what?
What are the ethical parameters around.
I appreciate it also,
so
I would kind of be a hypocrite because
even though I can ethically kill
something at 40 yards or just figuring
out what the number is,
depending on the size of the animal,
right.
Um,
even though I can do that,
I can do it way easier with a rifle.
So why am I using a bow and Arrow?
Why do I want to make it more difficult?
Why am I making it more challenging?
Why am I requiring myself to practice
this questions?
You're very self aware.
It's a very important question to ask
because if I was just doing it just for
the meat,
I would probably use a rifle,
right?
Yeah.
I think that,
that,
that part of it has to do with the
primal association with the kill.
And then the key question is how do you
want to indulge that?
What is the set and setting,
blah,
blah.
So that was the,
that was the thing that I found shocking
is that I had thought,
you know,
I understood something about the need to
control population.
It's the effect which really killed me
on this thing.
Well,
again,
we're talking about bears,
you know,
as such as bears and other animals as
well.
Yeah,
I mean I saw.
I don't want to focus more on it
necessarily,
but it's just a question I had to ask
you because I sort of.
I was very surprised by my own reaction.
Well,
a lot of people are taking issue.
My good friend Ben,
oh Brian,
who's a brilliant writer,
who's actually also a hunter,
is
advocating that people stopped taking
what he calls grip and grins with a grip
and grin as like say,
if you shot a beautiful deer,
you're holding the deer up by the
antlers and you're smiling and he's
advocating that those photos are
problematic because people who don't
hunt look at it like you're some blood
thirsty asshole.
That's super happy that something died.
And that's not.
Even though that's not how the people
feel when they're taking those photos,
what there are as happy.
That something which is very difficult,
which you know,
especially with using a bow.
Most people go home empty handed.
It's it requires too much fitness,
physical fitness,
because you're going up and down these
mountains and requires too much accuracy
and training and technique and archery.
Most people fuck it up and then there's
dealing with anxiety.
Most people fuck it up,
but
after it's all over,
there's this great feeling of elation.
Right?
You did it.
I can't believe it came together.
Wow.
Because it was probably not going to
come together and people get happy.
These are people again,
that already accept hunting.
Now if you take someone who is an animal
rights activist or someone who deeply
appreciates animals and then you show
them that photo,
they have a completely different
association with what that photo means.
What that photo means is,
here's an asshole who's a trophy hunter.
Let me get my thing.
I don't know any species that celebrates
a kill for food with glee chips.
Do chosen.
Sorry.
You're right.
Yeah.
When they kill a monkey,
they get pretty happy.
Well then they do it socially and then
they share it.
Uh,
you know,
through altruism,
they scream at each other in a.
So that's the ships are my least
favorite species.
Almost evolved.
They're terrifying.
Yeah.
It terrifying little fuckers.
So we're.
Where do you think we are on the
political front?
We haven't even touched that.
Um,
I think it's the same way as bowhunting
versus spears rifles.
It's all,
there's this world's messy,
you know,
all these things are messy.
Do you see a way in which this
political epic comes to an end?
The only hope that I have is through
reasonable dialog becoming an accepted
and appreciated thing,
a celebrated thing,
and that this is possible that people
can realize that there's some stupidity
to this team mentality that we have is
right versus left,
which is almost all a good percentage of
it is.
He's assumed identities,
right?
These,
uh,
these predetermined patterns that get
adopted in order to,
as we first started talking about this,
in order to establish yourself as
someone who's in a group,
you get accepted by this group and you
see it left and right.
I mean,
I don't want to name any names,
but there's a bunch of people that do it
blatantly.
You see them and I've even seen them
switched teams and you see them switch
teams and I don't,
I don't buy the rationalizations when it
comes to ideology,
but I think is what they're doing is
they're switching teams because they
realized there's an end on this team and
they can just say this is the problem
with the team.
I used to be on those fucking losers and
they're really benedict arnold,
right?
Like they probably have as much of an
affinity to the ideas of one side.
Is it do the other side.
They just go all in on one side to get
acceptance from the group.
You just no way.
People change their opinion that much
over two years or something like that.
Or they just decide this group makes
more sense now and I've been attacked by
people on the left so I'm going to go to
the right or vice verse and usually what
it is is when even when they say they've
been attacked,
like,
oh you fucking baby,
there's 300 million people just in this
country alone.
If you put something out there publicly
and a thousand people attack,
you don't act like you're being
persecuted.
Okay?
You have an idea,
you've,
you've.
You've launched that idea out into the
zeitgeists and people took a big shit on
it.
You know,
whether it's people on the right are
people on the left.
You got to be able to argue your point
one way or the other and not just
immediately jumped ship on someone who
shares ideas with you,
decides that your idea sucks and maybe
they're wrong and maybe you're right,
but you've got to argue that through,
but this idea of these partisan patterns
that people just seem to automatically
fall into there is so detrimental to
dialogue there,
so detrimental to us under really
understanding each other and really
having some sort of a sense of
community.
Right?
This is a giant community of 300 million
people.
That's what it's supposed to be and this
idea that it's this group is trying to
fuck it up and they're trying to turn us
all Muslims and this one wants everybody
to be gay and this one wants everybody
to fucking have free food and this and
this.
This is nonsense.
We need better understanding and and you
know the word better.
Education gets tossed around a lot,
but it also means better social
understanding,
better social education.
I got at appreciation of who we are and
why we think the way we think and
calling out weasels on both sides of the
pattern,
like calling out weasels on the right
that are pandering,
that are just trying to get unit,
the repeating a lot of these like
accepted beliefs because they know that
they can hit this frequency and a lot of
people sing along or the same thing that
other people are doing on the left.
They're doing it on both sides.
I think most reasonable people have a
collection of ideas that they share from
both the right and the left and most
reasonable people are reasonably
compassionate and I think that's one of
the things that we're missing some
reasonable sense of not just ethics,
but an appreciation for each other for
all of us as a group and do that.
I think if we can celebrate reasonable
conversations and celebrate and
understanding of other people's
perspectives,
be able to just look at how you're
looking at things and have empathy.
Okay.
Let me see where you're coming from with
this.
Okay.
Let me put myself in your shoes.
Instead of just immediately like,
fuck you,
you cook and fuck you,
you this.
And instead of thinking about it that
way,
if we just tried to just everybody
exercise a little bit more so we're a
little bit more calm and come at this
from a rational place and try to like
realize like it's
exclusion.
I've been experimenting with a very
dangerous idea.
I keep hearing,
but chief inclusion officers,
I thought about things from
ecclesiasticus to every season.
There's a purpose under heaven.
So if there's inclusion,
there also has to be exclusion and like
d platforming or unplanned forming
somebody is an act of exclusion.
And very often it's very interesting
that the people who are for inclusion
are very focused on the need for deep
platforming,
which is an act of exclusion.
So should we have chief exclusion
officers that both monitor who is being
excluded,
including somebody like James Demore,
uh,
at Google,
like is it ethical to exclude him or are
there certain voices that need to not be
at some tables in order for something to
make progress?
Because if you always have the voice
that the most extreme that doesn't
accept the game,
then it's very hard to move forward
within the game if you're constantly
being reminded,
you know.
So we had this,
um,
we have a series of situations in which
it seems like some perspective that very
few people hold terrorizes majority's or
know group of people who sort of can
more or less get along with each other
and keeps pushing us into this very
divided landscape.
And I was just curious,
you know,
in terms of our group of people that we,
we talk and hang out with a in common,
um,
where you see the high leverage,
uh,
is that we're,
we've just finished the midterm.
We've got this 20,
20 election.
It looks to me like Hillary is Kinda I
in whether she wants to get back in the
game.
Um,
this trump thing has completely,
uh,
you know,
it's like,
it's like the dress is it black and blue
or white and gold for like eight years.
And I just have you thought about how
this ends?
Well,
I would never be so presumptuous to
think that I have any idea how this
ends.
I have,
I've proposed various scenarios to
myself and I don't like any of them.
I don't like where it's going because
what I worry about,
and this is also again hypocritical that
because I think it probably should burn
down and be rebuilt from the ruins,
were not going to get such a clear thing
to be clean.
I know this isn't very clean either
though.
Honestly.
It's that guy won.
It's not clean.
Have you heard this?
He loves Putin.
You know,
this ain't clean.
the whole thing is weird.
It's a,
the bankers having the amount of
influence they have,
the fact that there's two lobbyists.
What is it?
What's the number like two lobbyists to
every member of Congress or to lobbyists
to every senator for the pharmaceutical
industry.
By the way,
the number of people that have influence
over the way.
Our laws are shaped.
It's so fucking bananas right now.
Right.
So,
so off the rails,
is that what it is?
Twelve,
but I didn't type in specifically,
but there's a 23 registered lobbyists
for every member of.
No,
I think from the pharmaceutical
industry,
they were saying not just,
I think it's two for every member of
Congress in the pharmaceutical industry.
Um,
yeah.
The question that you started out with
like d platforming people,
I think we're impatient and I think
we're,
we're.
We really want to make sure that this
vetting of ideas happens quickly because
we see the answer,
we,
we see the solution,
we see that this is incorrect and we see
these people that think the world is
flat,
are idiots,
and we think that these people that this
I think this and think that we think
they're all wrong and so we want to stop
them from talking,
but that doesn't work.
It just works for now.
It,
it,
it.
It oftentimes feeds those ideas and it
also,
it it.
You have to question like,
why are you so sure why you showed so
sure that you are correct that you want.
You don't just want your side to be
heard exclusively.
You want to.
You want to silence these other people's
ability to participate in this argument,
even if they're totally wrong.
I think that's dangerous because I think
that the way to fight off ideas that
aren't good is to introduce ideas that
are good and you're gonna.
You're gonna have a bunch of people that
agree with ideas that are bad,
but I think that that's a part of this
whole figuring things out,
like you need to have bad ideas floating
around there to appreciate good idea,
so if all the ideas are good,
like what do we do get it out against.
It's not bad to have these bad ideas
broadcast.
What's bad?
To not have someone,
hey,
these are bad ideas,
but I need to see the pitfalls of
racism.
We need to see the pitfalls of crime.
We need to see the pitfalls of
corruption.
We need to see it in action.
I think it's like stock market,
swindling.
I think in a lot of ways it's important.
We need to understand that this is a
pattern that people fall into
continually over and over again when
they have control over the money,
when they have control over the way they
move the numbers.
What do I do this?
How about if I tell you that this is
going to go down and then you invest
some money and I put some money in your
bank and we work together.
Let's make some money because what
people do right,
if they just fucking do it over and over
and over again,
should you punish them?
Yes,
absolutely.
But I think it's kind of important to
see some fucked up behavior just because
we're not done.
We're still in some sort of emotional
and psychological and even physical
evolution.
We're in the middle of this thing and I
think that bad ideas facilitate
comprehension,
like these really shitty ideas that a
lot of people have.
What they do is they facilitate a
comprehension of why we think dumb shit.
And sometimes you don't know why people
think dumb shit until you see someone
over and over again that thinks dumb
shit and you get to see that,
whether it's Alex Jones or whether it's
to fill in the blank,
what guide you want deep,
but I don't.
Okay,
so here's my thing.
I want a lot of our leading experts,
the platform.
Okay,
well,
you're going deep.
The spray paint fucking big a on Tucker
Carlson's driveway.
We mean,
well,
if I think about who the great danger
is,
is that Alex Jones,
uh,
you know,
who veers towards tin foil hat land with
some frequency,
or is it the people who were selling,
you know,
weapons of mass destruction in Iraq as a
response to nine slash 11 or you know,
the people,
let's assume that you're a reasonable
person on immigration,
you neither think that borders should be
opened or closed.
Um,
then you start hearing professors say,
you know,
the great thing about immigration is
that it has absolutely no costs and all
of them are better than all of our
people because,
uh,
you know,
they're highly trained,
they're highly motivated,
they're young.
You're thinking like,
okay,
what kind of thing has all benefits and
no costs.
You're not,
you're not even entering into rational
description and now we're hearing like
all these trade deals that got
negotiated.
Yeah,
that Kinda wasn't true.
All those things that we were telling
you that if you,
if you question these things,
you are backward protectionist and you
were just,
you were stuck in the old world and you
couldn't embrace the new.
Yeah,
that was all bullshit.
Um,
what I think is we have a crisis and
expertise,
institutional expertise,
uh,
is at an all time low.
Nobody really trusts any of our
institutions to be an authoritative
source of ground truth.
It's not to say that everything that the
institution say is wrong or everything
the experts say is wrong,
far from it.
It's just that there are almost no
experts or institutions that aren't
willing to distort facts in order to
pursue institutional goals that does a
giant issue.
Right?
Right.
And so I don't actually want a diy
platform,
these people,
but I do have the very strong sense,
you know,
when,
when I,
when Elon came on your show and Peter
Teal,
um,
my friend and boss came on Dave Rubin
show.
I thought that was quite a moment where
this alternate network of distribution,
which is not under centralized control,
started to be seen as comparably
powerful and important.
And I think some of the noises that
Tucker Carlson just made to Dave Ruben
about,
well,
hey,
you're doing this out of your garage and
you have the freedom to do anything.
I'm,
I'm beholden to the structure in which I
live word a very interesting place with
respect to what is this thing,
uh,
this alternate distribution network for,
for ideas that's unpolished by the
institutions.
And I think I've been convinced in the
last two days that I need.
This is advice that I got from you at
the beginning.
You said you need to start a podcast.
I think I need to start a podcast and I
think you need to start a podcast just
to keep going on about the hop thing
until people figured it out just about
the hot thing,
but we have to,
we have to return to some kind of stable
sanity that I'm positive that the
institutions can't return us to because
the,
the institutional interests,
uh,
really have to do with the fact that
certain kinds of growth on which they're
predicated,
their existence is predicated if
evaporated.
So all of these institutions are
extremely vulnerable to corruption at
the moment.
And the real revolution as I'm seeing it
is that high agency individuals are out
competing,
traditional institutional structures,
um,
in terms of mind share and some of those
high agency individuals are
irresponsible,
you know,
they're like Milo types that are kind of
trying to light things up and some of
them are extremely responsible and some
of them,
you know,
we'll do a few irresponsible things but
will self correct.
And this new world that is being born is
a huge check on the institutions,
but it's still largely separate.
Like,
am I right that you don't do a lot of
network television?
Oh yeah.
Anymore.
But I used to.
I mean that's how I became famous in the
first place.
Right.
You know?
Um,
but yeah,
I don't do it anymore,
but it's also because there's nothing
fun out there like this.
Like there's no place for this.
Right.
Other than this,
this is the only place you could do
this,
but isn't it interesting to you that we
still have not like Jordan had to be
dealt with by the mainstream because the
book was too big.
His affect was too large.
I think his effect on the Internet is
bigger than the book.
Yeah.
Think the,
the youtube videos and the debates that
he has.
The one that I was telling you,
the recent one interview with Gq,
so interesting.
It's really good.
The woman's very smart,
but she gets trounced and it's because
he's been
in the trenches with this stuff for a
long time.
I mean he,
he's,
he's fighting a very strange fight of
dialogue and have interpretation of
discussion and,
and the freedom of intellectual
sovereignty.
You know,
there's a lot of people that want you to
think a very certain way and use certain
words and say certain things and it
doesn't matter whether or not you are in
fact racist or sexist or homophobic or
whatever.
There's a weird battle of control going
on that it's a heart of it as much as it
is a battle of inclusion and diversity
and strengthening our overall
progressive mindset.
There's a little bit of that too,
but there's also an undeniable game
that's being played and people want to
win their scores.
They're being scored.
There's points on the board that
throwing in new agents,
they have teams going at it and whenever
Jordan goes on one of these
conversations,
these video interviews and as a feminist
and Jordan Peterson like,
there's a fucking game going on.
We're watching a soccer match.
We're watching a wrestling match.
This is Jujitsu there.
They're playing intellectual Jujitsu and
Jordan's really good at tapping people.
He's really good at and they get pissed.
They keep sending in new chicks.
They said that Kathy Newman Lady,
and she's like,
so what you're saying is that didn't
work.
Either.
She just got devastated.
She got rocked and this is what's
happening over and over and over again
because whether you appreciate what he's
saying or not,
he has some facts that are undeniable.
He has some positions that are based on
a rich understanding of history and of
Marxism and communism and have a lot of
the problems with people with compelled
thoughts.
If you're compelling people to behave a
certain way,
compelling people to talk a certain way,
and we're not talking about compelling
people to not commit crimes or violence.
We're talking about weird things like
compelled
pronouns and so if I take,
if I take your analogy because you
brought it up that he's like doing
Jujitsu,
so in some previous era I thought your
description of the early days of mma was
fascinating that we just didn't know
what fighting was,
so we didn't know who would win or what
systems worked and if you think about
the mainstream media is like a to some
system that maybe has some valid
validity in some very rarefied context
and it comes into general purpose
fighting systems and it's.
It's dismantled very quickly.
So now we have this weird situation that
we've got this new world of kind of rule
laden.
Anything goes discussions more or less
and the mainstream world doesn't want.
Like the Akita world doesn't want to
acknowledge that this weird ufc type
thing is happening.
How long does that go on for?
It goes on for as long as it takes.
And this is
similar to I think,
the what's happening intellectually,
and this is one of the reasons why I
don't think you should stop people from
expressing these bad ideas,
is one thing for stopping people to say,
hey,
we need to kill black people.
Stopping people said we need to kill
white people.
We need to kill.
Fill in the blank.
Whatever the group is.
Yeah,
that's,
that's different.
You're,
you're,
you're clearly stepping outside of the
realm of civilization and into war and
violence.
And we could all collectively decide and
we should all collectively decide we
should have ethics together.
Like whether it's right or left or in
the middle,
we should all decide,
hey,
you can't do that because what you're
doing is you're calling for violence
against someone who's not committing any
violent.
Can I pause you right there because I
think there's a really interesting
point.
Let's assume that we know that that
behavior needs to be downregulated in
some way.
You can try to silence the person where
we just physically duct tape them so
they can't say anything,
right?
You know,
we put them in jail.
Uh,
we don't give them access to the media,
et Cetera,
um,
or we can shame them or we can kind of
take them aside at what layer of this
sort of communication stack to very good
question.
We should.
Because I think one of the things that
we haven't done this to positively say
we agree with you that the speech is
offensive and it is potentially
dangerous,
but we think it should be downregulated
differently than the D platforming
option.
Well,
the D platforming option,
the real issue is there's only a few
different avenues for these people to
express themselves publicly.
Right?
And the,
the argument that's really strange is
should these be regulated like a utility
or should they be thought of as private
businesses get to decide what's on their
channel essentially,
like it's almost like a,
a,
a private NBC that everyone can
broadcast out if it's none of the above.
What if the problem is we're trying to
pretend,
is it like a dinner party,
is that the public square?
Is that the utility?
And it's none of these things.
I think these ideas,
what I was discussing that like there's,
there's a reason why good ideas and bad
ideas should go to war is the same
reason why even though I kind of knew
that most Kung Fu was bullshit before
the UFC.
I want those guys to get in there and
try,
oh,
you got some death touch.
Hey,
come on in.
I want to introduce you to a guy,
you know,
this is a,
his name's Cain Velasquez and you're
going to try your death touch and now
he's just going to wrestle to the ground
and beat your fucking brains in.
Okay.
But that's not going to happen because
you know,
death touch,
but good luck and you let them duke it
out and that is the,
that's what it is.
But it is a little.
No,
no,
but,
but when you deep platform people,
that's when it's not angry with you.
But what I'm trying to get at is that it
is.
I hadn't really thought about it the
extent to which Jordan is the only one
of us that they've really gone after
like this.
Well,
he's,
first of all,
he became famous from this,
right?
This is the battle was wha,
how he emerged.
He emerged from this battle over the use
of compelled pronouns for,
um,
various genders like the bread 78
different genders.
Similar but not okay.
The difference is Brett's position.
He comes from a different place,
the way they were going at him with so
much more than reasonable.
They were saying right away that what he
has to do is leave work because he's
white.
They were basically saying a racist
thing and everyone universally
acknowledged as racist,
except for the super lefties who thought
that it made sense because in their
mind,
every white person is somehow or another
guilty of at least at the very least
using your privilege to advance in the
world at the,
uh,
to the negative impact of people of
color and people of other ethnicities.
So they decided that they are going to
have a day of exclusion and instead of
this day of absence having black people
and people of color stay home,
they were going to kick white people
out.
So it became an aggressive act instead
of an act of appreciation,
it became,
uh,
an act of punishment or an act of
exclusion and by people that are clearly
out of their fucking mind.
That was also part of the problem is
their,
their arguments were incoherent.
You'd see that fucking stupid president
of the university standing in front of
those kids and they told him to put his
hands down because he was threatening
their,
you're,
you're scaring us.
You're making violent gestures with your
hands.
So he puts his hands down and they start
laughing.
This is nonsense.
Now you're in little kids.
You got little kids running lord of the
flies on a grand scale in a state
university.
And it's all.
I mean,
this is a public university,
right?
Yup.
I mean they get funding,
right?
This is all chaos.
Nobody agrees.
They got baseball bats.
They're looking for him.
If he's coming back to the school,
the kids form these vigilante groups
with weapons over what?
Like who's threatening you?
Like what is happening?
You need weapons.
But the big story there was the non
reporting.
What do you mean?
Well,
the New York Times,
Washington Post,
all of these major organs,
NPR,
they didn't report.
They didn't want to touch the story.
Well,
this is what this is.
My big theory here is that every outfit
that has a a grand narrative cannot
report the news that goes counter
narrative,
so racism by blacks against whites
cannot be reported by any outfit that
believes that racism is impossible by
blacks against whites,
that such a preposterous position.
The idea that racism is exclusive to any
group will,
but the redefinition of definition,
the redefinition could suck a fat dick.
It's a stupid redefinition.
That's true.
This idea that the only way you can be
racist as if you have power over that
other group.
That's nonsense.
Every human beings act as individuals
and they always have power over each
other.
You have
power to intimidate,
you have power to isolate.
You have power.
If there's more using about this is that
there is no pretense of consistency.
I mean,
on that side of the aisle,
it's like we're going to throw out the
following 17 completely contradictory
rules and then we'll tell you which rule
is operative in any given moment.
So,
you know,
I was going to throw out this concept of
the Hilbert problems for social justice.
So one of them is,
um,
you cannot understand me because my
experience is too different and you must
understand me because mine is so
important,
right?
Or,
um,
we're all similar enough that any
deviation from 50 slash 50 shows you the
amount of sexism in a workforce and we
are all so different that once you
include women,
uh,
in previously male occupations,
you will see a great benefit because of
the diversity of opinion.
Once he saw all these self-contradictory
couplets that you have to agree to.
Well,
that's the weird thing is who assumed
that I just buy all of your stuff.
I think we've made a terrible tactical
error.
We fought these bad ideas rather than
saying maybe we should just accept all
of your bad ideas and then show you what
kind of a weird world.
Yes.
No,
no,
no.
You can't do that because they don't
make sense.
You can't say,
oh yeah,
they make sense.
Men,
how do I know when you're serious?
Well,
but that's my.
Just let those through and does things
fail.
But that's my point is that by showing
the internal,
this is in mathematics.
We call this reductio ad absurdum that
once you take on too many different
points,
you show the conflicts showing that
those things can't all be true.
There's no way in which if I accept all
of your ideas,
I can run anything.
So,
you know,
take this thing about a trans exclusion
from Victoria secret,
right?
You didn't hear about this.
Oh God.
So the idea is that the Victoria secret
lingerie division head had to step down,
um,
where there was a scandal in the
background that somebody had said we
don't actually want a trans people
walking the Victoria secret runway.
Right?
And so very interesting.
You have a company that is dedicated to
the commercial exploitation of humans as
sexual objects for the privilege of the
male gaze.
And now you're angry that it doesn't
include trans into that exploited class.
So just without,
without getting into whether this makes
good economic sense or anything,
there's just the issue of self
contradiction,
but isn't that a reductionist view of
what Victoria secrets is?
Isn't it possible that a woman can feel
empowered and sexy if she's wearing
lingerie and it's not just to the
exploiting of the male gaze that they,
that she appreciates looking attractive.
Wonderful.
So take that off.
Okay.
Right.
Exactly.
So the idea is that you're both going to
say I'm a,
that that's a positive female
empowerment issue and it's a terrible
male expectation as you at the same
time,
terrible male exploitation issue.
Like what if a guy likes what if women
decide universally,
they like guys who wear leopard skin
underwear and guidestar wearing leopard
skin tidy whitey underwear.
Well this is sexual selection but,
but yes,
but,
but it's the difference between that and
women wearing lingerie.
If women wear lingerie and they do it
because they like to be an interesting
stat and they liked to be more try,
that's what they're to accentuate their
attracts.
So then the sexual self objectification
is an interesting issue.
Is that an issue of empowerment or is an
issue of oppression?
It could certainly be.
Well,
that's what if a woman's health to take
that,
take that all on.
Why does it have to be exploitation
though?
That's the question,
but what I'm trying to say is you've t
some point.
You've made too many arguments.
There's this concept called the
principle of explosion in mathematics.
The principle of explosion says if you
can get one contradiction through
airport security,
you can blow up the universe as soon as
you allow a single contradiction in the
unity of knowledge,
everything can be proven right,
so everything becomes meaningless.
So the game in some sense in mathematics
is frequently to say,
well,
let's take all of those beautiful things
that you believe.
So you've just created some done seated.
Some throw them all in.
Instead of saying what's true and what
isn't true,
you say,
are these compatible?
And these ideas are clearly
incompatible.
So for example,
one of the tricks that I use is to look
at advertising for women to women and
what phrases get used.
So if you used the phrase turn heads the
summer in quotes and put it into a
search engine,
you'll find all sorts of revealing
outfits that are intended to court the
male gaze.
You say,
well maybe that's not really the male
gaze.
So then you put in a phrase like make
him drool and that will be used to
market to women.
And so this issue about can we at least
get to a point where we're talking about
the internal contradictions of your
position?
Like I,
I don't even want to get into what my
position is.
The first thing that's scaring me is
that you've said so many things so
strongly and so dogmatically,
and this doesn't have to be about
gender.
It could be about race,
it could be about class,
but when once you've said too many
things,
then I can say,
look,
I don't see any way of squaring all of
your positions and it's not.
It doesn't even have to do with me.
I think that's where we haven't gone to
yet.
So you think letting them come up with
as many preposterous things as possible.
And then once it gets to a position
where they,
the,
the idea's contradicted each other,
expose that.
Well,
that's my point,
which is once you've told me all of your
principals,
then I'm going to say,
great,
I'm confused.
Do you feel that I have to understand
you or that I can't understand you
because I don't know which is operative
in this situation.
Tell me the rule how I decide which
principle that you've stated governed
this situation.
Right?
So if.
Go ahead.
One
last point about that.
I don't want to have to refer to you
where you say,
well,
you bring,
you bring me each individual situation
and I will tell you which principals
operative in which principals
inoperative that doesn't work.
I want you to list your principles,
enlist your mechanisms for resolving the
conflicts within your principles.
And then once you've done that,
we can actually evaluate what you're
saying.
But at the moment it requires you as an
oracle to tell me which of your many
contradict your seemingly contradictory
positions is operative in every
particular case.
So for example,
we did that one with the person who was
the quantum,
uh,
ex Muslim,
trans,
you know,
everything going on,
which is operative,
the person with mckayla phobia,
which is a extremely rare psychological
condition,
or the person who appears to be a deep
into some self,
uh,
you know,
some radical self actualization
principal or even a person who wears
that crazy makeup should be able to wear
whatever they want.
It's nothing wrong with it.
You should be able to dress like Paul
Stanley from kiss,
if that's your,
to assume that that's true.
But what if,
for example,
as a heterosexual male,
you don't want to watch,
um,
uh,
the crying game at the Victoria secret
runway show.
Do you think that,
wait a minute,
do you really think that Victoria secret
runway shows for the heterosexual male
in some sense?
Yes.
What guys,
has he ever watched a Victoria secrets?
That's what the guy said.
He said it was a,
he's branding it as.
No,
no,
no.
I mean,
there's something between a fantasy of
Victoria secrets.
A senior executive recently told that
trans models don't belong in the fantasy
of Victoria secret's fashion show.
Well,
you know,
that's,
that's on him,
you know,
I mean he wants to be the.
But just because he said it doesn't mean
it's true.
I guess if you looked at the graph of
male to female viewers have a Victoria
secrets.
I have no idea.
It would be like a few prepubescent boys
and the vast majority of women and maybe
some gay guys,
but that's it.
Is that right?
It's got to be without fuck is sitting
around with on honor an hour.
What are you doing?
Oh,
again,
some popcorn ready for the Victoria's
secret fashion show.
Dogs coming over and Mike and we're
going to drill to TV thought fuck Outta
here is porn and then there's everything
else.
Everything else is for chicks.
Okay.
Runway Shit.
I don't know the single guy out there
watching runway shit.
It's like,
remember when playboy had play girl?
That was her gay gay dudes.
Not for chicks.
Right?
They don't want to see that and we don't
want to see runways.
We're not.
We're not here for runways.
We get bored easy bunch of chicks
walking around in their underwear.
I think you're calling it very.
You may be right about who the audience
is.
I have no idea on the demographics.
I've never watched one of these in my
life,
but it's not the case that I believe
that male,
the male gaze is nowhere to be found
here because it's a very weird thing
that the female is largely buying a an
amplifier for something that is supposed
to excite a male,
but it's.
It's a little bit to me like the female
is the magician buying magic supplies at
a store for the audience.
Right?
Sure,
sure.
That's a good way of looking at it.
I don't think there's.
The male gaze is absent.
I just don't buy his interpretation at
that.
It's a fantasy for men.
It's ruined with Trans men or trans
women.
I don't.
I don't have.
I don't have a dog in that fight.
Seems silly.
It seems silly.
It's like if you don't want transgender
people to be in there,
you just have to say you can't say.
It ruins the fantasy.
He just say,
I will only hiring people that have
vaginas,
I don't know,
do whatever you want.
Like you can.
Like there's certain jobs if you go to
Chippendale's,
like our trans women shown up,
trans men,
are they at chippendales where they're
down there because they don't have a
dick and but they're all jacked and they
looked like a man is just what women
want to see and are they transphobic if
they don't want to see that.
If women go to a,
you know,
one of those all mail review shows and
it's all trans men,
but they're heterosexual and they're not
really into trans man.
Are they all phobic?
Yeah.
So what I'm trying to get at is there's
a hierarchy,
like I'm not that interested in this,
in the particulars of Victoria's
secret's profitability and what their
statements are.
What I'm more interested in is you've
cut,
you've annunciated so many.
There's so many different principles at
work as to what should govern in a
conflict that you won't tell me.
Well,
okay.
When these two things,
these two beautiful things that you've
said actually lie in conflict,
how do you resolve the conflicts and it
seems to be,
well,
why don't you consult us on every single
one of these and we'll tell you a case
by case and that can't work because what
I want to know is I don't want to
appoint you as an oracle.
I want you to state what your positions
are.
I want you to state how you harmonize
them and then we're having a
conversation,
but as long as I have to keep going to
you and your crazy definitions and
you're well,
this is operative on,
on Alternate Tuesdays,
then it doesn't work.
I completely see your point.
However,
you can't give ground.
You can't give grounded nonsense because
that ground was never get back.
You never getting it back.
If you allow them to establish certain
ridiculous principles,
rules that are contradictory to each
other,
they'll come up with a reason why they
make sense.
No,
no,
no.
You don't allow them to put it into the
workforce.
You say,
look,
before we put it into the workforce,
let's just understand the 17 different
things that you've said.
Are absolutes.
Well,
you're basically doing then what Jordan
does and every single one of these
debates,
you letting people lay out their idea
and then you shoot them down and you
decide what's.
What's logical and what's illogical.
I think that's.
That's the UFC of ideas and this is why
it's important to let these shitty ideas
into the match.
Why do we still have so much caught up
in the Akita League
in the country?
Because it sounds good.
People liked the idea that you don't
have to learn much.
You could just go in there with a death
touch.
Fuck people up.
They don't want to think that all you
have to practice for 10,000
hours.
You have to sprawl and work on your leg
kicks and working with this public
shaming is death touch well,
debating these.
I think honestly,
and I'm not trying to blow Air Jordan's
horn anymore than I already have,
but I think what he does is very
important because he is one of the few
that engages in these people,
in these very public forums,
in these long form debates where they go
to war with ideas and these are way
better their conversations because
because he's fucking good at it,
they want to chop them to not picking
you so much because I'm friendly.
I'm not as like,
I'm not as combative as he is,
so I send them also not as smart as he
is and I'm also not as.
I'm not,
I don't have credentials.
I don't have the credentials that he
has.
Like when he is the University of
Toronto professor,
a Phd,
when he's going to war with these
people,
they're,
they're throwing out valiant warriors to
die at his sword.
What did you hear?
What to watch?
Bread and Richard Dawkins.
Cargo.
So what happened?
They appeared on the stage for the first
time.
They oppose each other.
Oh yeah.
Really?
On religion.
Oh,
well,
it's Dawkins now.
Religious?
No,
no,
no.
Dawkins is staunchly in that a sort of
new atheists,
aggressive guys.
I panic because I know you had a stroke.
Oh,
okay guys.
You know what I'm saying?
I thought your brother was an atheist as
well,
but Brett doesn't think that religion is
a virus.
It's not Paris.
He believes that religion is actually an
adaptation and the weird thing was is he
said,
look,
there's young Dawkins and there's old
dock and young Dawkins came up with
these two powerful ideas.
The idea that the meme,
the unit of ideation a is a,
is a gene like object.
He also came up with the idea of the
extended phenotype.
So when you talked about that ant mound
that you were excavating,
that ant mound is in some sense part of
the and strategy.
It's such a.
it's so deeply tied in that you have to
consider the ant mound is part of the
ant system because it can't exist
without that complicated underground
city.
Right?
Right.
And so what he said was,
okay,
if I use these two concepts,
that memes are like genes and the genes
can throw off a bad meme instantly.
So genes,
memes have to ride on a gene and they
can't parasitize it too much,
and you also have this inclusive
fitness,
which is,
that may be religions co travel with us
and allow us to outcompete those who
don't have them because they seem to be
found everywhere.
So prevalent.
Right?
You have to,
if you looked at it objectively,
not looked at it in terms of you know,
how you feel about cult like behavior
and people's susceptibility to
influence.
If you just looked
at it objectively,
if you were from another dementia and
you'd go,
well,
clearly this is a part of being a
successful person.
Tell me about it.
Exactly.
So Brett,
Brett and Dawkins met,
and I think Dawkins had this kind of
reaction like,
Oh crap,
I'm meeting an ultra Darwinist who's
read my work,
taking it seriously and is feeding it
back in and saying,
you,
Richard Dawkins,
in your younger years,
established ideas.
Who,
when that,
when those ideas,
logical consequences or explored,
it completely negates your late life
hatred for religion because it reveals
it to be an adaptation rather than a
pair of citizen action of the human
species.
You know what?
The real problem that I've always had
with Dawkins and his take on religion is
not that he's wrong or they're right,
it's his anger that he has when he's
talking to people that believe,
yeah,
he,
he sets,
he sets up the kind of like heavy
conflict that,
you know,
the way people interact with each other,
right is very.
The reactions are very dependent upon
the attitude that a person has when they
go into this interaction,
you know,
with two people meet on the street,
one person,
the one person meets that person says
the same words and they wind up hugging.
Another person meets that person and has
a fistfight.
Like what?
What is,
what's the difference?
Well,
there's a lot of it is the way you
approach people a lot of is the way you
accept people's ideas,
the way you communicate with them,
the way you allow them to fully express
themselves without judgment.
And he doesn't,
he doesn't buy any of that.
He feels like there's a war going on and
he's got to shut down religion as
quickly as possible.
That's the thing he wanted to.
He wanted to fashion a science into a
cudgel that was maximally efficient for
beating the crap out of religion.
That's a great way to put it.
And what Brett did is to say,
actually your scientific work goes in
the exact opposite direction.
The reason I brought it up was it was
one of these unexpected occurrences that
when you have a meeting of these things,
and this is your point about the UFC,
is that the mixed martial arts thing
was,
hey,
we don't know what's going to work.
We don't know what's going to have.
Nobody knows anything yet.
And gradually we came to understand that
there were certain systems that were
hyper effective and that even those
could get,
um,
you know,
you were making the point earlier about
Brazilian Jujitsu didn't keep advancing,
uh,
at the same level once we understood the
role of all of these different systems
and advancing fighting.
So the question that I'm having
repeatedly is what kept Brett and
Dawkins,
for example,
from having that meeting,
um,
where I think dawkins probably didn't
fully understand what he was getting
into when he agreed to appear within
evolutionary theorist on stage.
But you don't,
you think that he's just very confident
in his ideas.
He's very confident,
his intellectual capabilities,
he's been doing these types of debates
and shutting down these secular or these
people that are from various religions.
Right.
I mean,
from,
he's,
he's had these debates with people from
Judaism,
from Christianity.
He has been as part of his career.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean,
and even what the fuck's his name?
Uh,
the Indian fellow who,
uh,
everybody makes fun of,
what the Fuck's his name?
Dinesh D'souza?
No,
the other guy,
the one,
the,
the quantum guy.
That's always using that guy,
that guy,
that guy is constantly using
inappropriate quantum words,
throws quantum into fucking vegetable
soup and tries to make it to make sense.
He,
he used a lot of word salad,
you know,
and um,
I mean,
I've seen him debate him too.
Yeah.
But you liked these videos of the fake
martial arts guys and they,
they,
they show up for the challenge because
they've actually bought it.
Same with Dupo Depok.
Well,
this is what I'm trying to trying to get
at.
Isn't it interesting that in general,
the people who say,
you know,
immigration is a pure good.
There is no connection between Islam and
terror.
The only people who oppose a free
trader,
protectionist.
These people know enough not to want to
trounce us because what they're saying
is wrong.
Right?
And they're expert enough to know that
they are,
they've got a secret five point
exploding heart technique or something
and then they know it's nonsense and so
they won't actually think they do.
Well then why don't,
why don't they want in?
Um,
I don't think they,
I don't think they necessarily do
actually believe that they're wrong.
I do think that some of these people
that are like super progressive and
very,
very committed to some of these maybe
illogical positions on some of these
ideas are afraid of conflict though.
And I think that's one of the reasons
why they shy towards progressivism
towards socialism.
I don't think they let conflict.
Some of them.
No,
no,
no.
They like to get together and scream at
people.
This is what they'd like to get,
get,
get together in large groups.
Say We know how you sleep,
you fucking racist you fucking piece of
shit,
but one on one.
They're cowards it like this is,
this is the type of person that would
think it's a good idea to,
to show up and bang on someone's door
and scare them in their home.
That type of person is not the type of
person that would,
that looks forward to on an even
battlefield engaging someone one on one
and just just open communication.
That's not what they're dealing with.
They're doing is trying to silence
people,
scare people,
intimidate people.
They're bullies,
intellectual bullies.
People are bullies are almost always
insecure.
They're almost always scared.
So this is why there's been very few
people that are jumping forward to,
to try to go to intellectual war.
When Rachel maddow or um,
Linda Sarsour one in.
I mean,
they're pretty.
You're dealing with two very different
types of human beings.
So Rachel Maddow,
it's one thing.
Linda Sarsour is a very,
very seriously
religious person who's got some,
you know,
very deep beliefs as far as Islam.
She wears the hijab or she'd been just
as two totally different.
No,
but it.
But if I listed a group of people like
the late night comedians,
there's this very weird thing that they
all seem to believe the same.
Like there was a secret meeting that
they all agreed to a bunch of stuff that
I,
I want to see the conference
proceedings.
Like what's,
how so?
Well,
just that they all kind of know that the
Republicans are,
are all horrible.
The Democrats are basically good people,
that they,
they all know that climate science is
settled science.
I mean,
there's some that they have these pretty
much open borders are a great thing and
that everybody who doesn't believe in
that is only so it's only not believing
it because of xenophobia,
whatever these set of beliefs are.
I don't see these guys in open
discussion particularly,
you know,
two hours long.
Well,
I don't think it's a.
That could,
could you get a Stephen Colbert,
Seth Meyers in here and have a
discussion.
My guest is really.
Yeah,
I'm sure.
I'm sure they'd be solid.
They're scared of having discussions
with people,
but I only see them in ovarian.
They'd have to be very measured because
they could lose their job.
That's not,
it's not that simple.
They make a tremendous amount of money.
Right?
If they came and said,
uh,
anything that could be misconstrued or
misinterpreted,
even not even actually being something
that's actually transphobic or
homophobic or actually xenophobic,
if they said anything that could be
taken out of context and put it in a
small clip and then sent down and it
goes viral and they're done.
Look at Megan Kelly.
Megan Kelly had a question about why
can't you wear makeup to look like Diana
Ross?
Why can't you?
Well,
there's some good reasons why you can't.
There's some good racial history behind
blackface.
However,
why is it that she can't even ask a
question without losing her job?
Like that's it pulled up blog Kute.
We have to make a fucking statement.
We have bore violence,
but for exactly what you said about,
about the whole Kung Fu thing,
that is only can exist in a protected
context.
Well,
first of all,
someone like Megan Kelly can only exist
in a protected contest with all these
people protected contest.
Even Cole bear is got to be one of the
fastest minds on the planet that
everybody I know who's smart,
who's done his show says he just thinks
faster than you do.
Well,
I'm sure he's a very smart guy,
but.
But he's also a Catholic devout.
Yeah.
That.
Does this bother me.
It bothers me.
It doesn't bother me as an organization
of kid fuckers.
Well,
well how come he's not speaking out
against all those kids getting fucked?
Well,
if you're a Catholic,
like I was raised Catholic,
I mean I'm not saying that he is,
I'm not saying that the people,
he knows our,
but this is a giant
problem with that organization,
but.
But that's not what's bothering me.
What's not bothered with what I want to
make sure that we're talking.
I think we're about to talk past each
other,
so I want to bring it back.
Okay.
I think you just gave me an answer.
He can't appear in this kind of a
context because that might come up
and he,
he needs to be in a world with much more
restricted rules where someone can't say
it's an organization of kid fucker.
That's right.
Yeah.
And it's not just more restricted world
that that's the reason why that has been
able to survive.
That's what I'm trying to get that
people don't talk about,
but is the idea that this is such a
risk.
Like your point about Akita was if you
happen to be unarmed and attacked by a
man with a sword,
this might have some value.
It would have some value of someone that
attacked you in a very specific way.
It didn't understand what the key.
So the idea is that that's a very
restricted rule set on which to fight.
Right.
So now maybe what you just said to me,
which could open this whole thing up,
is that all of these people can only
apply their ability to have a back and
forth of ideas if the rules are heavily
restricted.
I don't necessarily think that's the
case.
I think they could do it in other ways.
I think all of them are operating under
this rule system because this rule
system is how they get paid.
But I think Seth Meyers a very smart
guy.
I know Jimmy Kimmel,
he's a very smart guy.
They can do whatever they want.
He could do a podcast.
He could do anything.
He could operate into any in any genre I
believe.
And I think I would imagine the same
with [inaudible] I,
I mean I think Jimmy Fallon st thing,
but when they're forced into that box
and this is 100 million dollar a year
box,
you know,
it feels good and that box was fucking
velvet walls and you get to drive a fat
Mercedes and live in Beverly Hills.
Dude,
did you decide to stay in that box?
Maybe their mind is in that box.
Maybe they on a regular basis,
maybe there's not any restriction for
them at all because this is how they
operate all the time.
So I did the show with a Jordan and Ben
Shapiro on Dave's a set right before Ben
Wind on real time with Bill Maher.
And Ben was kind of excited to do bill
Maher and said,
oh,
I don't think he's going to rough me up.
I think he's going to be a gentleman.
I think he's one of us.
And then when ben sat down with bill,
we saw this thing that was very.
We were sort of hoping because bill is
kind of the most towards us,
if anybody in that kind of mainstream
environment.
And what I saw,
which I hadn't really appreciated,
was that bill was not doing this kind of
open discussion thing.
A lot of his tone was leading like
surely you're not going to say that.
Know.
It wasn't just purely saying are you
saying that it was all of this emotional
instruction?
Yes.
And it was clear to me that when I saw
Ben on that in that context,
that there were only a few hours
separating the two appearances and that
the characteristics of that environment
and we're builds show is the most like
this show,
that it's just too different.
It's not,
it's not really the same ecosystem.
And you couldn't have an open debate
unless it cuts off after seven minutes
and the host is in control.
Well bill doesn't have any time that
well,
this is part of the problem.
Part of the terms of they have a very
restricted format.
He was doing a conversation with Steve
Bannon and he was on Sam Harris' podcast
and he was talking about it and he said
that one of the problems was he got to
this point where like I was wanting to
ask him more stuff,
but I ran out of time and I heard that.
I was like,
what the fuck kind of ancient system are
you operating under that you run out of
time,
but let's take.
Let's take him at his word.
Well,
he definitely did run out of time,
but I assume that that's true and so
that Bill Maher said,
hey guys,
I want to.
I want the following situation.
I want to continue to do realtime in the
same format that it's always been done,
but I want to have a podcast like Rogan
where we take as much time as we need
and I don't think those two things play
together.
Oh,
they're fine together.
Yeah.
I feared that the,
that they're not.
Well,
here's the thing.
He went on Sam's podcast and I've.
I enjoyed him more than I enjoy him on
the show.
I know because he had chances didn't
look the same way on Dave Rubin show
though.
He looked totally different.
How do I didn't say it?
Oh my God,
you got to see it.
Um,
you know,
Tucker,
uh,
you know,
I'm having my own weird issues where I
used to,
my previous position was that Fox News
is just propaganda and that Tucker was
in that old car,
a crossfire situation way back when
Tucker was like opening up as a
different person saying you have the
freedom.
You're the new.
I'm still stuck in the old.
Well,
he must really feel that.
You must really feel like he is like,
look,
that is what you have to do if you want
to survive on Fox News.
And again,
it's a velvet coffin.
You're in there,
it's beautiful.
Yes,
you're getting paid shit.
Loads of money,
but you don't necessarily have the
freedom to express.
First of all,
you don't have long form freedom,
right?
And you don't have the freedom to
completely express yourself across the
border.
Like you could.
You can't look at the left's ideas and
say,
you know what?
I really liked the idea of universal
healthcare.
basic income.
I really liked the idea of paying for
people's school job.
I think you and I actually have a really
interesting difference of opinion.
I think your opinion is there is nothing
preventing you from staying in the
velvet coffin and doing this style of
podcast.
And my guest is.
I'm not saying that.
I'm only saying that with Bill Maher.
I think Tucker Carlson probably can't do
that.
I think of Tucker Carlson left colby or
do it.
Yes.
I don't think so.
I think he could.
I don't think he would though.
I think he out of all of them and I
think he's brilliant and don't get me
wrong.
I'm what I said he's from,
uh,
an organization of kid fuckers.
Uh,
it's not him.
I mean,
but he's a part of the cabinet you could
do.
You could do any one of these people.
They're all bright.
Do you think is a big thing?
It's a big thing
in terms of,
first of all,
the actual reality of the organization
and what they've done to protect people
that have molested children.
It's unprecedented,
right?
It's also something that I was raised
in.
I was Catholic.
I went to Catholic school.
I don't think that he wants to do that
sort of wild country open type Internet
show.
I think he enjoys wearing a tie and
doing a straight up talk show like the
Johnny Carson show or the Jay Leno show
and I think he's a very,
very good at it and I don't think
there's anything wrong with that.
I think a lot of people like that France
and I understand that,
but I think that's him.
I might be wrong.
I'm just assuming I could do different
of what a what an action that if you
tried to do both of these things,
you will be revealed.
You'd be caught between two worlds where
if I see what you're saying,
like I actually think that a lot of
these ideas would collapse just the way
Kung Fu collapsed.
I think you're probably right.
I think if you had two people having
these conversations in long form,
instead of those CNN,
a three windows where they're just
battling it out for six minutes and then
you know,
everybody's yelling over everybody.
That is the single worst way to argue
ideas.
I think there's no gracie challenge.
There's not.
Well Jordan Peterson is kind of doing
his own grave challenge that because
gender.
Yeah.
And he's the only one they want.
Yes.
Well,
which is,
which is I think a puzzle hoists Gracie
of the intellectual.
He's out there tapping wrestlers.
Um,
yeah.
I mean I think I'm not legitimately now
he's worked his way past the Kung Fu
people and he's now onto like a Olympic
wrestlers,
like they're throwing at him this,
this latest one was very good.
She is much better than Kathy Newman
lady.
She didn't make any of these ridiculous
Straw man arguments.
She,
she came at him with her positions and
our points.
It was interesting.
I think what you're saying is true for
everybody except Bill Maher.
I think Bill Maher would hold his
positions in podcast form and I think he
would just have more time to expand on
them and I base this on him being on Sam
Harris,
his show and I find it to be very good.
It was the 10th anniversary of religious
and he was excellent on that.
I think he could do it,
but I think he's also.
He can say,
fuck you.
He got in trouble for dropping in n bomb
on his show in a joking for him.
I mean he's a different cat.
The whole thing is very different with
him.
He's on Hbo,
but when Ice Cube came to him and said,
you can't do that.
It was painful to me because I'm just
positive that he had a Carlin style
attitude about that word.
That's tough because in this
environment,
again,
that's where he makes his living.
He butters his bread over at HBO and if
you wanted to have a long form
conversation with that guy even on a
podcast and he didn't have an hbo show,
that's one thing,
but if you do have an hbo show,
you have to have a totally different
attitude.
One
wrong.
You're walking a tightrope,
but this is what I'm trying to get at is
is that we're too dangerous in some
sense to play with because the velvet
he's.
He's asked to.
I've talked to bill and I actually went
back and forth on an email about
something.
I dropped the ball,
but no,
he would do anybody's podcasts.
I don't think that's the case.
He could do his own podcast as well.
I agree that he would be the one most
likely to be able to do both.
He could do it.
Yeah,
he could do it.
I think all of them could do it.
I think Seth Meyers could do it too.
I think Jimmy Kimmel could probably do
it as good or better than any of them.
Jimmy absolutely could do it.
I mean,
the only thing that's holding him back,
he's a man of his ideas.
He's not gonna.
He's probably the least likely to alter
or manipulate his ideas of anybody
that's ever done one of those late night
talk show host.
He's just operating inside a format
where you don't swear and you have a
certain amount of time and you try to be
funny and you say insightful stuff,
but he's a very ethical guy and he's
also a very,
very smart guy and he's also very rich.
He's got a shitload of fuck you money
and I think Jimmy Kimmel do it easily.
I think a lot of people could do it
easily and I think they're going to have
to.
I think some some point along the line
they're going to realize that the
restrictions that they're operating
under,
unless they really enjoy that format,
I don't think those formats are going to
be there that long.
I think those formats are a lot like
sitcoms,
like they're slowly starting to vanish.
You know,
for every one the Roseanne show that
comes up,
which is kind of nostalgic and you know,
that runs into its own disaster.
How many new sitcoms are there that
everybody's aware of?
Shit.
It used to be every time there was a new
sitcom,
whether it was friends or you know,
fill in the blank,
whatever the show Seinfeld there was.
Everybody was talking about these new
sitcoms.
Nobody fucking talks about sitcoms
anymore.
This is the,
this is the thing I took on this morning
on twitter,
which was a Dave Rubin and Bret
Weinstein and myself were talking about
this phenomena of very high follower
counts with cycle low engagement.
Oh yeah,
that's fake.
But those are fake followers.
That's what that is.
Well,
it may be,
but it's a lot of it.
But it's very interesting that we're
talking about getting rid of visible
follower counts and getting rid of
likes.
Who's saying that?
Um,
apparently there's discussion about a
Jack May have floated some trial
balloons that twitter is going to try to
improve the level of conversation and by
getting rid of follower counts and
removing likes can imagine thinking
you're going to improve the level of
conversation by getting rid of a heart
that you can switch it on someone's Id.
Art,
it's literally a heart,
but it's feedback.
You're clicking on a heart.
It's on instagram and on twitter it's a
heart.
It's like,
here's your little heart.
I love you.
I'm going to get rid of love Jack.
Come on,
Jack.
Going to get rid of love,
terrifying human being.
Why?
What?
What's terrifying about it?
Because I'm seeing you blowing kisses in
my general direction.
I'm remembering all the videos I've
watched where you attack some sort of a
punching bag with this vicious spinning
elbow or something.
I'm just thinking like,
okay,
listen,
we're talking about ideas here.
You can't.
No,
I want to get out on that stuff later.
I want to have a midlife crisis with
some instruction for.
I think we got to end this.
We've done four hours and 10.
Are you kidding me?
I to show you what they said though.
This was just a couple of weeks ago.
We've been saying for awhile,
we are rethinking everything about the
service to ensure we are incentivizing
healthy conversation that includes the
like button.
We are in the early stages of the work
and have no plans to share right now and
this is in response to telegraph the
Telegraph saying twitter to remove the
tool in a bid to improve the quality of
debate.
I think something really weird is going
on.
What is the quality of debate and by
whose definition I mean,
and you're not gonna you're.
You're definitely not going to change
the way people interact with each other.
You're just not.
People interact with each other because
they're anonymous.
They have incentive to talk shit.
It's fun.
Okay,
so the one thing I could ask you as we
close this thing out is if we could
plug.
I'm not only my twitter,
which is my main thing that I'm trying
to diversify into instagram and youtube.
Should I get shut off twitter?
Are you worried about getting shut off?
I'm always worried,
but you don't say anything inflammatory
like would you?
You're very logical and reasonable guy,
so you think it's really gotten to that
point?
Well,
yeah.
I'm actually worried that by being
logical and reasonable,
I have more of a risk because the things
that I'm saying,
like we're also recognizing intellectual
and very left wing.
Your progressive.
So why would they shut you off?
Oh,
I think because they're much more
worried about a progressive.
Who says that the current
progressiveness is absolute stupidity.
That's much more dangerous than some
right winger.
Who was always against anything that's
progressive.
Interesting.
There's a war of foot.
You love that kind of stuff.
You'll have that cloak and dagger type
Shit,
don't you?
Yeah.
Well,
I'm part of the ineffectual Dork with
your stuff.
I don't say ineffectual.
I know you said international direct
web.
Yeah,
that's what I call.
Listen.
I have to.
I can't call myself a part of the dark
web.
That's just too ridiculous for a man in
my position.
Okay.
We'll see what the.
That to one of a thousand people that
speak the humor across the lands.
Listen,
this is effortless.
Yeah,
I can do this.
I did that.
I had no idea it was four hours flew by.
It was awesome.
All right,
well you can I just tell you,
just give the,
the,
the names please do.
All right.
I think I am.
It really is 5:10.
She's Eric r Weinstein on.
No,
I'm Eric r Weinstein and twitter.
I'm Eric Weinstein,
Phd.
I think on instagram and on my
instagram.
Uh,
I linked to you on the Instagram,
Eric r Weinstein,
instagram,
and I'm on Youtube.
Eric Weinstein.
Phd.
Yeah.
And if you can't find his instagram,
I linked it on my instagram.
All right Joe,
thanks for having me with you,
my friend.
Lots of fun.
Alright,
bye.
You fucks.